Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Lousнее Musik.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Auch was für Kinder.
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen!
Zwei Minuten nicht mehr
Schnell Sub, du huck sieben monat dankeschön
Huge Sub
Okay, ich trau mich mal ein bisschen hochzustellen
Ich trau mich mal ein Stückchen hochzustellen
Also ich mein so zwei mbit bräuchten wir schon
So zwei mbit bräuchten wir schon dass das halbwegs ansehbar ist
Ja anscheinend anscheinend geht das jetzt
Ich muss mal nach dem stream checken ob die mich nicht wieder auf
Duel stack lite umgestellt haben oder so ich mein ich ihr wisst dass ich doppelt bezahle nicht
Duel stack lite zu haben aber man weiß ja bei unity media nie
Die jebaiten einen
So zwei mbit scheine auch ganz gut zu funktionieren
Sind wir mal sind wir mal mutig sind wir mal mutig
Ich mein wir sind in deutschland wir sind für deutsche verhältnisse sind für mutig
Mal gucken was jetzt passiert leute was was meint ihr monka smoke oder es geht
Ich meine es geht nicht
Wah
Wahnsinn ich trau dem frieden aber nicht so ganz echte heckermanns brauchen mehr mbit
Wahnsinn
Mbit
Es scheint zu gehen
Probleme mit meiner leitung
Ich glaube da kann man nicht mal von probleme sprechen systematischer kack von vodafone
Aber leute ihr wisst ja woran es liegt oder
Der erste der im chat der mir sagt woran es liegt gewinnt eine klo rolle klo papier rolle
Da der tribot hat schon gewonnen es das id doppelt genau
Es ist die doppelt
Kacke okay
Es scheint zu funktionieren dann können wir anfangen
Ich mach das jetzt
Warum heute bin ich jetzt lauter als sonst
Das ist auch wieder so was geiles
Windows kann sich ja aus prinzipen nicht entscheiden ob es laut oder leise sein will
Es ist jetzt ein bisschen zu laut so bla bla bla bla test perfekt
Nicht zu früh freund ja zwischendrin ruckelt das bestimmt
Sagt mal leute kennt sich von euch irgendjemand ich hab das schonmal gefragt
Kennt sich irgendjemand von euch aus wie das mit kompressor aussieht
Ich würde ganz gerne irgendwie so ein halbwegs gleiches gleiches level von von mikrofon lautstärke haben ohne
Übersteuern und halt auch ohne dass es so extrem leise ist teilweise
Und halt auch ohne dass ich immer extrem gleichmäßig reden muss oder so
Kennt sich irgendjemand mit kompressor settings aus
Ich hab da nämlich ich blick da überhaupt nicht durch
Okay aber aber anscheinend geht es jetzt also wenn sich einer mit kompressor settings auskennt kann er mal schreiben
Ich würde das nämlich gerne mal ordentlich einstellen
Audio kompressor
Chat der wird zwar nach dem ersten mal schreiben raus mit dem reifen kompressor
Jetzt tut es nur noch weh
Der milchmann hat gesubbt auf stufe eins für neun monate
Huge sub
3xTi Subscriber
Sagt er mit dem atemlos witz im video ich fand den atemlos witz
Ich fand den super
Okay so wir hoffen jetzt einfach mal vodafone hat seinen shit zusammen gekriegt
Das funktioniert jetzt
Wir laden mal das aktuelle manjaro iso runter
Also eine sache worauf ich noch mal euren euren focus richten möchte
Passt mal auf
Das dürfte die richtige größe sein
Fällt euch was auf
Und merkt stellt ihr was fest
Ich hab den ram eingebaut genau
Ich hab mir ram gedownloaded
So und ich hätte mir wie gesagt beim einbauen fast den arsch gemessen ich
Zeige euch mal kurz warum
Während das iso runter lädt
Dass man die e-modes wieder auf sinnvolle größe stellen
Und zwar ihr wisst ja dass ich einen noch wobei ich muss ich ich muss das
Eigentlich gar nicht zeigen
Ich hab doch hier letztens die guides max fps rechner wir haben so
Letztens die guides als
Liste vor meinem rechner angeguckt so
Genau da steht nämlich auch was es für ein lüfter ist
Also ich habe das mainboard
Das mainboard und den lüfter
Ich hoffe man sieht dass man es gibt vielleicht sogar ein bild davon
Ja hier sieht man es doch hier sieht man es richtig gut
Fällt euch was auf was lüfter und und ram bänke
So ein bisschen problematisch werden lassen könnte wenn man wenn man
Fetten ram mit kühlrippen hat
Lüfter falsch rum eingebaut
Ich hab den lüfter nicht falsch rum eingebaut
Ich hab den rechner auf die seite gekippt aufgemacht
Ehm reingeguckt hab gesagt ah gut hier passt noch ein ram rein aber scheiße
Hier ist der lüfter drüber
Und ich war sehr erleichtert als ich gesehen habe
Dass tatsächlich da drunter noch platz ist
Ich mein man musste den ram jetzt hier so kippen
Hier drehen ohne ihn zu sehen und dann irgendwie hier reinfuddeln
Und dann versuche den runter zu drücken
Und dann hatte ich den ram auch noch falsch rum drinne
Darf jetzt nicht fragen wer mit IT kram sein geld hier verdient von uns
Und ich hab den rechner aufgemacht und hab das hier gesehen
Aber ich hab gesagt scheiße der passt nicht
Und wie gesagt ich war wirklich sehr erleichtert dass der doch gepasst hat
Deswegen hab ich jetzt 32 g ram
So und wir machen jetzt curvy mal aus und machen ein bisschen die ärzte an
Ich hab extra extra was für euch rausgesucht hier
Ich hoffe das ist jetzt weder zu laut noch zu leise
So und deswegen können wir jetzt folgendes machen
Wir können jetzt die absolut pock vm erstellen
Nämlich mit pass mal auf
Hast du schon das neue Lied von ersten
Du meinst das hier
Ne wie heißt die auf bademeister tv oder so
Heißt die nicht bademeister tv
Hä wo ist es denn
Du meinst das hier
Ja das fand ich jetzt nicht so tolle
Und eins ist mir mal aufgefallen ne
Ich dachte ich dachte ja immer die werden nicht älter
Und die sahen auch lange zeit halt halt immer gleich alt aus
Aber mittlerweile sieht man schon dass die älter werden
Es geht an keinem es geht an keinem spurlos vorbei
Zum einrichten machen wir noch mal was anderes an
Ich brauch irgendwie ein bisschen was entspannenderes
Nintendo elevator music
Ok das ist echt das ist echt Fahrstuhlmusik
Das ist wirklich tolle Fahrstuhlmusik
Wir hatten mal nen Entwickler bei uns
Und zu zeiten als wir quasi neue software versionen nur nachts und nur am wochenende
deployed haben
War ich mit dem mal zusammen da und der hatte ohne scheiß
Der hatte vier stunden am stück
Der hatte solche musik vier stunden am stück laufen
So fahrstuhl jazz vier stunden am stück
Und er hat auf seinem stuhl gesessen und hat auch noch so geil gemove dabei so
Geile musik geiler Hört euch das mal vier stunden an
Der ging voll drauf ab Max wird auch mal alt aussehen
Ich seh jetzt schon alt aus Meinst du wie wenig Haare ich noch hab
Hmm
und
Oh
N voll
Das war erstmal das, so also, Ticken Ticken lauter können wir machen.
Kann sich YouTube mal entscheiden wie laut ihre Musik ist?
Die schwankt total.
Okay, so also wir können jetzt die übelste POG-VM anlegen.
Ah ja ja Intensifies, oh ne ne ne ne, Intensifies machen wir jetzt nicht.
Max hat mal gesagt ungenutzter Rahmen schlechter Rahmen, ist ja auch so, ist ja auch so.
Der Rahmen der für nichts benutzt wird ist überflüssig, umsonst, hat mal umsonst Geld
ausgegeben.
Wer ist das Audioplugin was im Chrome, du meinst, Volumemaster, man müsste, man müsste
echt ein Chrome Plugin, ein Chrome Audioplugin machen was GatchiBase heißt oder?
GatchiBase, also wir können uns jetzt die absolute POG-VM anlegen und zwar, also das
wird, das wird ein Linux, das wird ein, wir gucken aber, dass wir möglichst weit kommen,
weil das haben mich viele gefragt, auch immer wieder über die Streams, so nach dem Motto
was hab ich für einen Linux am Start, wie ist das ganz eingerichtet, was ist das für
ein Window Manager, was ist das für ein Terminal, was ist das für eine Shell und wir hatten
ja schon mal angefangen im Stream eine Manjaro VM einzurichten vor drei Monaten oder so,
aber ich hab Big Brain Move gemacht Leute, ich hab ja gesagt wir fangen jetzt an dich
VM einzurichten, machen den nächsten Stream weiter und irgendwie hab ich das Ding auf
eine externe Platte geschmissen und hab dann die externe Platte, also war eine SSD und
hab die dann an eine Kiste angeschlossen und formatiert und dann war die vor allem
weg, Massive, Massive Brain, oi, ja richtig, oi, es könnte aber auch Leute, vielleicht
versteht ihr das Ganze auch nicht, vielleicht hab ich die auch absichtlich gelöscht, dass
ich jetzt mehr Content für den Stream hab, das wäre dann nicht so, das wäre nicht so,
das wäre schon wirklich Next Level, oh das ist Mario Galaxy Musik, so und das beste
ist jetzt, wir nennen das jetzt mal hier Poggers und die Location, die geht immer hier nicht
hin, sondern wirklich auf die neue SSD, mal einen neuen, für neuen Ordner, für VMs, so
und jetzt Poggers VM, wir können jetzt richtig reinhauen, 4 CPUs und der erste im Chat der
mir sagt, wie viel 16G in MB sind, gewinnt wieder eine Klorolle, 4x4096, MrMr687 hat
gewonnen, huge, ich muss jetzt natürlich mal nachgucken, ob das stimmt, weil der Chat,
beim Chat weiß man nie, neu, ja, ich hab mehr RAM jetzt, wir machen jetzt mal 4x4096, 16384
und der Chat hat recht gehabt, muss jeden Tag neue VMs konfigurieren, ja gut, dann kennst
du dich mit sowas aus, ne, das Shackle, das mag ich nicht, das ist mir zu minimalistisch,
das Shackles Terminal, ah die Musik, da geht, so, also wir können jetzt 4 CPUs dem Ding
geben, 16G RAM, bam, können sie ruhig erstmal hinter Nutt packen, das stört nicht weiter,
default, default, create new disk, single file disk, machen wir gleich 100G, gleich
bam, wobei 100, da sind die Leute bestimmt geträgert, machen wir 128, ok, ich will jetzt
die Leute nicht wegen Scheppenzahlen hier irgendwie in Verlegenheit bringen, nächstes
Mal eine Linux from scratch, na, ich hab ja schon quasi from scratch im Titel stehen,
ja, aber das reicht dir wahrscheinlich nicht, so, single file, speichert es jetzt auch,
was, du sollst es nicht unter download speichern, das ist nicht für Apple, E-Doppelpunkt,
VMS, ah, da kannst du speichern, kannst du nicht, kannst du nicht speichern unter downloads,
also meine SSD gleich voll, ich brauch keine Festplatte, wir haben keine Festplatte mehr
in unseren Arbeitsrechnern, da sind wir schon ziemlich modern, das Geplinke von meiner Tastatur
nervt mich gerade, next, jetzt ist die Musik ein Tick laut, oder passt die Musik lautstärke
so, ne, ich glaube es passt ganz gut, ich glaube es passt ganz gut, so, und jetzt eine wichtige
Sache, die wir machen müssen, man muss immer, also erstmal mal den Drucker weg, Soundkarte
und so geduldens können wir lassen, also was ich immer mache, ich mach Bluetooth Devices,
shareen aus und stelle das Ding auf USB 3, man weiß ja nie was man mal so anschließen
will, und eine ganz wichtige Sache, die wir unbedingt machen müssen, die ist also auf
der nächsten Seite, eine ganz wichtige Sache, die wir unbedingt machen müssen, ist das
hier, ich glaube das ist hier umstellen von BIOS auf UEFI, es funktioniert beides, also
es war jetzt übertrieben, das ist aber ganz wichtig, es funktioniert beides ohne Probleme,
aber irgendwie wieder strebt es mir noch BIOS Systeme zu installieren, BIOS ist legacy,
wir machen UEFI, wenn schon dann, wenn schon dann schon, doch ist doch ein Tick laut die
Musik, aber mal so, ok, nice, safe, und jetzt haben wir eine 4 Kerne 16G RAM 128G, das ist
besser als viele Hardware Rechner, so auf gehts, schalten wir an, ah, vielleicht soll ich mal
das ISO einlegen, das wäre auch mal was, habe ich das ISO jetzt eigentlich runtergeladen
oder nicht, habe ich das, ah, yes, ich habe das ISO nicht runtergeladen, exellent, aber
jetzt etwas HP dazu geben, wie dasSOP, FIFTHEK, wie ****, hmm, ja, das ist ein gem
Unread Message
Geil, hab ich noch nie reingeguckt
Okay, also wir
Nein
Alter geht das geht nicht gut
Wir legen eine CD ein, das ISO und installieren
den ganzen Krempel
Was will der jetzt hier
Und wir installieren auch garantiert keine Windows 10
sondern wir installieren mal den aktuellen
Manjaro Architekt
und rebooten den ganzen Shit
Zack
Eine gute Connect
Wir rebooten das Ding nochmal
So, da ist er
Äh, ich mach mal kurz Vollbild
dass man auch ein bisschen was sieht
CD
Ja gut, im Prinzip ist es ja eine CD
Ja
Ähm, ich überleg grad
Für was steht, für was, für was steht
ein ISO nochmal
ISO Fight
Für was steht ein ISO nochmal
Äh, steht das hier irgendwo
ISO
Education, was bedeutet das
Äh, das glaube ich nicht, dass ISO dafür steht
Ah, ISO ist
Ah, das ist doch ein Standard, okay
Ah, das ist ein Standard
und die Organisation
die den Standard rausgehauen hat
ist die ISO
und weil die Leute keinen Plan haben
haben sie es trotzdem ISO genannt
Achso
Das ist mal so eine typische Bullshit Abkürzung
wie man es oft findet
Also was haben wir? Time Zone, UTC
Wir haben nicht UTC
Wir sind nämlich in Europa
und wir sind in Berlin
Also wir, na
Zeit Zone
Key Table ist
Deutschland
Language ist ENUS
Also ihr wisst ja, ich lasse meine Betriebs-
Ich lasse ja alles immer auf Englisch stehen
Hat den riesen Vorteil, man findet besser
Fehlermeldungen, wenn man suchen muss
Driver Free
Davor kommen, egal
Übrigens, eine Sache muss ich euch nochmal mit dem Windows
mit dem Windows Task Manager zeigen
Eine Sache muss ich euch nochmal mit dem Windows
Task Manager zeigen, was mir aufgefallen ist
Also erstmal, was
ähm, sehr merkwürdig ist
wenn ich hier einen Overlay
mache, über den Task Manager
dann braucht man eine Grafikkarte mit der
Zeit immer mehr GPU-Speicher
bis irgendwann bei 20%
warum auch immer
und jetzt was ganz merkwürdiges, guckt mal
der Task Manager
ruckelt, seht ihr das?
ist, ist
ist der Graph so
highly
advanced, dass man den nicht
verschieben kann, ohne zu ruckeln
und guckt euch mal die
Grafikkrauslastung an
und die CPU
und es ruckelt, seht ihr wie das ruckelt?
das hin und her schieben
von so einem poplischen
Auslastungsding
kauft ihr eine
vernünftige Grafikarte
ich hoffe ja, dass es demnächst
Ray Tracing Task Manager gibt
weil ohne Ray Tracing kann jemand
Task Manager nicht verwenden
ok, wir booten mal
Electron, ihr Clocks HD macht keine
Witze drüber
mich würde nicht wundern, wenn der Task Manager
irgendwann demnächst wirklich eine Electron Anwendung ist
Microsoft hat ja keine Hemmungen mehr
der
Visual Studio Installer
ist Electron
Visual Studio Code ist Electron
übrigens, wenn ich Electron sage, meine ich nicht
unbedingt 100% nicht Electron
Skype ist auch Electron, Teams ist Electron
wenn ich Electron sage, ist es für mich
stellvertretend für
Desktop Anwendungen
einen Browser in der Desktop Anwendung
Bist du eigentlich Anti-Mac?
Nö
man ist generell blöd, wenn man
aus ideologischen Gründen
irgendwie Anti
irgendwas ist, wenn es um Technik geht
es gibt ein paar Sachen, die ich nicht mag
am Mac
es gibt auch viele Sachen, die ich an Windows
und Linux nicht mag
und es gibt sehr viele Sachen
es gibt ein paar Sachen, die ich nicht mag
es gibt aber ein Ding
ganz ehrlich, es gibt ein Ding, da mag ich
viel mehr Sachen nicht
als Sachen, die ich mag
und wer erredet, was es ist
gewinnt auch wieder eine Rolle, Klopapier
ich hab's schon oft genug im Stream gesagt
Scheiße
der Chat, warum
warum kennt sich der Chat so gut aus?
KyoKun hat recht, C++
warum weiß der Chat
alles heute?
der Chat weiß heute alles
C++, der hat's doch schon gesagt
der Chat kennt sich aus
also was wir jetzt gemacht haben
bis jetzt kriegt das glaub ich auch jeder gebacken
wir haben im Prinzip
den Rechner von
dem CD oder vom USB-Stick gebootet
also Rechner in Anführungsstrichen
weil es bei mir eine VM ist, funktioniert aber
mit einem USB-Stick an der Stelle hier ganz genau so
so, also wir wollen das Ganze
in Englisch installieren
wieso magst du C++ nicht?
ich weiß nicht, ob ich das, wenn ich mit dem Thema
jetzt wieder anfange
dann machen wir die nächsten halbe Stunde nichts anderes
das ich über C++ rente
ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist
ok, next
Moin Heinrich
ich mein
ok, eine Sache
ich sag nur eine Sache zu warum ich C++ nicht mag
eine Sache
warum
hat C++
keine Methode
standardmäßig in der Standard-Library
in der String-Klasse
um einen String von kleinen Buchstaben
in Großbuchstaben
umzuwandeln
warum?
jede popliche Furz-Programmiersprache
bis auf BrainFuck
hat das dabei in der Standard-Library
C++ nicht
in C++ muss ich mich mit irgendwelchen komischen
Standard-Transform-Begin-End-Iterator-to-Upper-Geschiffs rumschlagen
das sagt schon alles
das ist wirklich
kann die Musik vielleicht einmal einheitlich laut sein?
egal, das lassen wir jetzt
Boot-Partition soll er erstellen
auch gut
512MB Boot-Partition
128G
Rest, so ist das gut
So, Raid
richten wir keins ein
LVM-lich richten wir auch nicht ein
und Verschlüsselung-lich richten wir auch nicht ein
ZFS richten wir auch nicht ein
das ist alles in der VM-Syllos
zumal die VM selbst, der eh auf dem Verschlüssel-Laufwerk liegt
also das wäre jetzt doppelt gemoppelt
so, Mount-Partitions
hier muss man aufpassen
der Manjaro Installer
macht die ganze Sache zwar ein bisschen einfacher
wie wenn man sich direkt in Arch Linux installiert
aber
es sind nicht alle Sachen sonderlich
logisch, zum Beispiel
man darf jetzt nicht auf die Idee kommen
wenn hier irgendwie was von Mount-Partition steht
es kommt später noch ein paar mal mehr
Mount-Partition, Mount-Partition
man darf nie die Boot-Partition nehmen
selbst wenn er sagt, man soll alle nehmen
weil die den Leuten das Leben
schwer machen wollen
hier steht es in dem Fall da, Select-Root-Partition
sprich, da wo das System drauf soll
und das ist die mit 128G
so, wir nehmen ganz normal
ein stinknormales X4
jawoll
X4 Mount-Options lassen wir auch
so
also einen Swap-File
weiß ich nicht
ob man einen Swap-File machen soll
wir haben 16GB
RAM
trotzdem
ist es manchmal nicht verkehrt
noch mal so ein bisschen
8 oder noch mal 16G
Swap hinterher
zu schießen, weil
heutzutage ist RAM
total schnell weg, überlegt euch mal
man hat eine IDE laufen, man hat vielleicht
Visual Studio Code für Web-Sachen laufen
man hat einen Browser laufen
mit 18 Tabs
also 16G sind
so doof es klingt, relativ schnell
weg heutzutage, weil halt
nichts mehr großartig optimiert ist
und alles RAM
bis zum Gegner frisst
also vielleicht
machen wir doch einen Swap-File
wir haben eben 16G
wir haben 16G RAM
wir machen noch einen 16G Swap-File
Perky, Agnostic
also ich hab schon lange keinen Swap
eigentlich mehr
ich hab jetzt ja außer in dieser VM
ich hab auf nichts mehr Swap
ich hab auf meinem Server
keinen Swap mehr
ich hab auf meinem Robbo keinen Swap mehr
geht eigentlich ohne Probleme
aber nichtsdestotrotz
du hast recht
ich würde es also
jetzt wenn ich die Sache neu installieren würde
würde ich auch wieder einen Swap machen
weil ich hatte es schon oft genug
dass der Kram
mir hängen geblieben ist
bzw. halt rumgespackt hat
weil ich eben
drei Jetbrain-IDEs auf hatte
Visual Studio Code ein paar Tabs
und zack
ja, du hast recht
Perky, ich würde es jetzt genauso machen
also wenn ich es jetzt neu installieren würde
würde ich auch Swap machen
deswegen machen wir jetzt auch 16G Swap
guck hier, das ist sowas wo
hier gebated dich der Installer
select additional partitions
in any order
dann denkt man jetzt natürlich
man muss diese Partition
also man muss diese Disk selecten
was nicht stimmt
und die muss man nicht selecten
das ist
nur
für big brain Leute der Installer
dann
ja weil jetzt
muss man die Boot Partition selecten
wir machen System Deboot
das ist in VMs ganz praktisch
ich brauche den ganzen
Magic den Grub macht nicht
System Deboot ist in VMs vollkommen
top
das habe ich gerade auch nie
in die Situation dass ich mal
von Hand Kernel Parameter ändern muss
oder was auch immer
ich habe hier immer ein laufendes System da unten drunter mit dem ich was machen kann
auf dem Notebook
sieht es wieder anders aus
auf dem Notebook wo es vielleicht bei einem Update mal irgendwie
was zerschießt und ich einen anderen Kernel
booten muss und sonst was
da ist mir ein Grub lieber, weil in dem Grub
gehe ich beim booten rein, drücke E
und wähle aus was ich will
aber in der VM
machen wir das nach Boot
System Deboot und gut ist
Dual Boot VM
ehrlich gesagt
auf so eine Idee bin ich noch nicht gekommen
Dual Boot VM zu machen
ok
Pacman Configuration
eine Sache die ich immer in der Pacman Configuration
mache ist
ich mache die Farbe an
wenn ich es finde
Color
wie sucht man in Nano?
Nano
hör mal auf
Color
da
x
excellent
yes, wollen wir haben
ich glaube
ich fühle mich
mit Nano so wie sich
Leute am Anfang mit Wim fühlen
ich stehe da immer komplett planlos
davor
Pacman Mirror Config
will ich nichts editieren drinnen
jetzt
von welchem Server er am besten
Sachen runterladen kann
er testet jetzt alles durch
von Australien über den Iran
das letzte Mal war das Problem
dass der Iran irgendwie 5 Minuten Timeout hat
die haben gerade andere Probleme gehabt
als Manjaro Server zuhause
im Iran
Annele Time angesagt
Legend Krieger
Twitch Prime, Dankeschön
Huge Sub
XT Subscriber
Prime
Subscriber
so die Dänen sind heute auch nicht sonderlich schnell
das ist Dings hier, das ist Mega
Mega Man X oder?
ne
das ist Castlevania
fast
Hongkong
Hunger
ich hab auch Hunger
Indien
Indonesien
das dumme ist
dass man das nicht abbrechen kann
mir reichen
die französischen, deutschen und
österreichischen Server aus
ich brauch keinen indischen Server
Kenia
wusste gar nicht, dass in Kenia Manjaro
rausstehen
Niederlande, Norwegen,
Philippinen
wohne ich überall
die Comets sind auch am Start
wusste gar nicht, dass
da auch Manjaro mir rausstehen
Ich glaube, die haben ihr Update-Skript auch angepasst, dass es timeoutet nach 2-3 Sekunden
weil das letzte Mal haben wir hier gesessen
haben irgendwie 3 Minuten auf den Iran-Mirror gewartet
kann mich noch dran erinnern, zwar übelst langsam
ich weiß nicht ob das hier im Stream war
oder mal wo ich selbst installiert habe auf dem Notebook
im Iran wird noch von Hand getippt
wenn eine Anfrage kommt
ich weiß nicht, ob das hier im Stream war
oder mal wo ich selbst installiert habe auf dem Notebook
im Iran wird noch von Hand getippt
wenn eine Anfrage kommt
also jetzt wählen wir die
unsere Mirrors aus
Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Schweiz
Deutschland
kann immer noch eine aus den Niederlanden
und noch einen französischen
exzellent
save
übrigens wer jetzt nicht erkennt, wo man hin muss
man muss hier unten auf das
OK
also das ist sehr gut zu erkennen
springt regelrecht ins Auge
ok da unten
Back
so jetzt muss er erstmal die Keys
aktualisieren von den Entwicklern
also sprich
oder generell die Keys welchen
signierten Paketen er traut
das ist insofern wichtig
und das ist das warum unter Windows
auch unter anderem so viele Leute
sich Viren runterladen können
wobei das stimmt nicht so ganz
Windows hat mittlerweile auch sowas
man kann mittlerweile
oder schon lange man kann unter
Windows auch Software signieren
und Microsoft warnt mittlerweile auch
mit so einem blauen Bildschirm wenn man
unbekannte Software startet
aber hier ist es halt der komplette Paketmanager
das heißt ich installiere mir Software
nur mit offiziellen Paketmanager bis auf ein paar
Ausnahmen mit signierten Paketen
ich weiß auch was ich kriege und kriegst immer aus der
gleichen Quelle es aktualisiert sich und ist
top
installierst du privat auch über diesen tollen
grafischen Installer
du meinst den hier
das ist die einzige Art und Weise wie man
Manjaro Architekt installieren kann
wenn man sich das einmal angeguckt hat
ist es nicht so wild
ich mein es ist im Vergleich
zu einer Arch Installation ist das
eine Erholung pur
die Musik kommt ihr bekannt vor
was ist denn das
ah F0
genau
findest du angenehmer ich weiß nicht
wahrscheinlich habe ich
normales normales Arch zu wenig
installiert ich persönlich mag
Manjaro auch nicht unbedingt
gerade wegen diesem Installer
was ist da der Vorteil
zum Manjaro GUI Installer naja dass du halt
absolut minimal System hast alles so machen kann
wie du machen kannst wie du willst
was mir an Manjaro eigentlich ganz gut
gefällt ist
hast du auf der einen Seite die ganzen User Repo Geschichten
und sonst was von Arch hast aber
die offiziellen Pakete halt
1-2 Wochen so ein bisschen zwischengestaget sind
und man nicht den direkten Pleading Edge
Kram abkriegt
die haben ja nochmal so Zwischen Repos für Manjaro
das ist eigentlich das was mir da am besten
dran gefällt
der Rest mache ich je selbst
bei mir ist an Manjaro außer dass ich die Manjaro Installer
verwende kaum wirklich Manjaro dabei
So
Choose Pacman Cache
ja mach wir wollen das rüber kopieren
alles gut
das ist auch so eine toll beschriebene
so eine toll beschriebene Sache
Do you want to use FSCK
Hook
Chat euch ist sicherlich klar was der FSCK
Hook ist oder
also diese Dialogbox erklärt das
auch so gut was das für Auswirkungen hat
Äh ne mir ist doch kein Arch abgeraucht
Ähm
das
möchte uns sagen dass es quasi
beim booten die Festplatten auf Fehler
checken kann
irgendwie sowas es ist aber sehr kryptisch
also man hätte da durchaus schon mal
einen kleinen Hilfetext drunter schreiben können
was damit eigentlich gemeint ist
der zensiert
das kann natürlich auch sein
So
Back
Install Desktop System nein wir wollen
install CLI System was ist denn
ein Custom System habe ich noch nie angeklickt
Äh wir gehen mal back
wir installieren das CLI System
Base Packages
Die Musik weckt die Erinnerung
was ist das jetzt
Ah natürlich
Skyward Sword
Mir kommt immer nur bekannt war die Musik kennste
aber ich habe Schwierigkeiten das zuzuordnen manchmal
So wir machen mal was anderes
ihr wisst ja normalerweise verwende ich
Tritzen als Paket meiner Tor
Aber wir machen jetzt mal
wir machen es jetzt mal mit J
so als Kernel nehmen wir den aktuellen
Linux 5.5
Linux 5.6 ist gerade
Beta, Alpha, Merge
was auch immer
der aktuelle Linux Kernel ist ein 5.5
Kernel Headers installieren wir auch
ich geb den Header
ich header
Kernel Headers installieren wir auch
weil falls wir irgendwelche Sachen später
noch kompilieren müssen oder sonst was
machen wir einfach mal
Kernel Headers zu haben kann
oder Linux nix schaden
also das hier ist
das hier ist vor allem bei Workstation
die Musik
ich hab übrigens noch zwei Brötchen liegen
ich muss nebenbei noch ein bisschen was futtern
dann
also nicht jetzt klar ich hab noch kein Hunger
später
dann muss man noch irgendwie ein Essen Video angucken
bevor ich meine zwei Brötchen dann gehts weiter
das ist Dings
das ist die Musik
ist das Tales of Symphonia
nein F-Zero
fuck alter ich bin so schlecht
mit Nintendo Musik geworden
wahnsinn
natürlich das ist jetzt wo ichs weiß
ist es F-Zero
das ist eigentlich mit
das bekannteste F-Zero Ding
also ich muss sagen E3 verhält sich bei mir in der VM
super
ich hab ja E3 auch auf meinem Notebook auf der Arbeit
also sprich ich benutze täglich mehrere Stunden
E3 native in Anführungsstrichen
da wächst da eigentlich wenig
Unterschied
du kannst ja mal gleich gucken mit dem Resize
also ich mach nix großartiges jetzt
ich mach E3 erstmal drauf
VMware die VMware Tools fertig
das hört sich an als piepst ein Handy im Hintergrund
also ein Smartphone
Handy ist ja out
Handy
so was haben wir jetzt zur Auswahl
Network Drivers, Free Drivers,
Proparatory Drivers
oder Select
ok
Select
ha
jebaited
ok
Manjaro Installer Team
wie wäre es damit
das zu checken
bevor ich die Dialogbox kriege
dass ich die Dialogbox erst gar nicht
anklicken muss
dass ich eh nix machen muss
das wäre doch mal was
das ist richtig
jebaited gewesen
ok install bootloader
system.de boot
yes excellent
configure base
generate f
fstub
fstub ist die Datei wo balinux drin steht
wo solche
laufwerke an welche stelle eingehängt werden
und ich nehme eigentlich
ausschließlich nur noch uuid
da kriegt jeder festblatt jedes device
eine eigene einzigartige nummer
und damit wird die gemounted
device name ist ein bisschen doof
weil das könnte durchaus sein
dass es mal wechselt
label kann man auch machen
ich nehm ich nehm immer das
hostname
hostname ist eindeutig
poggers
system lokale
language wollen wir englisch haben
aber für time und date
das kann man unabhängig
einschalten wollen wir deutsch haben
das hat nämlich den vorteil
dass die sprache komplett auf englisch
aber urzeit
und währung ist dann halt euro und
und 19.14
ach ne
zeitzone kommt jetzt übrigens erst
aber währung ist dann halt euro
zeitzone
europe
berlin sind wir
yes
wir haben utc
ja mein wegen
set root password
eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs
ich brauch währung gar nicht aber es gibt
ein paar andere sachen die davon abhängen
ich kann ja aus dem kopf aber nicht sagen
was alles was alles ist
aber ich stell die das ist nicht nur währung
das ist zum beispiel auch wo der punkt ist
in tausender trennzeichen
ob es ein punkt oder ein kommer ist
und wie da punkten das kommer also
das ist schon nicht schlecht wenn man das auf was stellt
womit man vertraut ist
ja es sind da zum beispiel auch kilometer
und meter
anstatt ounces
und geschiss
also das ist schon nicht verkehrt
add new user
max
wir fangen mit der bash an hat nämlich
nen grund ich verwende ja eigentlich immer
zsh aber
die zsh ist kommt irgendwie merkwürdig
vorkonfiguriert und die bash so gut
wie gar nicht deswegen installiere ich mir dann
das von von von hand gleich
so password für max
eins zwei drei vier
fünf sechs
eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs
big brain password
custom packages
also die sachen die wir immer brauchen ist
einmal ein tmax
ein wim
ein hartop
so die basic sachen die ich immer brauche
was braucht man sonst noch
ach das reicht standardmäßig erstmal
dhcpd
ne das machen wir anders ich mach
den network manager dann drauf das
ascii aquarium
das ist standardmäßig gar nicht drauf doch
wichtig
genau genau ja
ob man yes oder ja eingeben muss und so was
wobei das das ist
das ist sprache das hatte ich ja auf englisch stehen
aber bei währung wie gesagt bei währung
ist es so der tausender trend zeichen und so was
gitmus drauf das mache ich nachher von hand
im prinzip da braucht man eigentlich nichts großartig auswählen
system tweaks
ok enable
automatic lock in no
hibernation wollen wir auch nicht
performance
lassen wir default
lassen wir default preload
wollen wir auch nichts
back
security
da stellen wir mal auf 50m
bin ich ganz sicher was das macht ich glaube wie groß
das system delog wird
core dumping können wir disablen
ich debug da eh nix drauf
restrict to
kernel
hier will ich eigentlich brauche ich da nichts restrikten
back
und fertig
jetzt können wir uns noch die installation angucken bevor wir booten
aber ist
ist eigentlich nicht wirklich notwendig
wozu wir machen exit
und gehen wieder in installer
back
done
es sind keine grafischen drei bei install
yes ich weiß
wir wollen es nicht rüber kopieren
und jetzt rebooten wir und wir sollten in unserem neuen system landen
wenn ich es nicht verkackt habe
da sind wir
so max
iiii
der pc speaker ist an
pc speaker
hypermonkaS
wie letztes mal stimmt
ich krieg meine maus nicht mehr rüber
wenn ich jetzt hier mal
gucke
ich hab keine ip adresse
das werden wir jetzt relativ einfach fixen
ich hol mir mal
ich hol mir mal eine ip
und das als allererstes was wir jetzt machen ist
wir aktualisieren mal unsere pakete
ich glaube so
ne so
ne doch
ok
und als erstes installieren wir jetzt mal
unseren window manager
dass wir was sehen
achso ne
bevor wir unseren window manager installieren
sollten wir vielleicht
überhaupt noch mal eine grafische oberfläche installieren
da kann ich mir die pakete nicht merken
da müssen wir mal nachgucken
ich glaube
was braucht man xorg
xinit
installation
was braucht man denn
x
ah hier
xorg server
xorg x
das brauchen wir dass wir den ganzen kram überhaupt starten können
xorg hotels
also die zwei
auf jeden fall
ne yoghurt mag ich nicht mehr
yoghurt ist outdated
also was was xorg xinit
ne warte ich hab schon wieder verpeilen
xorg server
xorg xinit
hast du schon mal wayland probiert
ja vor einem
haben wir sogar einen stream gemacht vor einem jahr
oder so
oder vor zwei Jahren ein Jahr
da hatte das in der vm übelste probleme noch
so und jetzt können wir
e3 installieren
dann haben wir auch gleich ne grafische oberfläche
so
dann machen wir start x mal gucken was passiert
er startet x aber
er kann nichts starten weil er nicht weiß was er starten soll
deswegen müssen wir
ne xinit
rc anlegen und schreiben einfach nur mal i3 rein
und er sollte jetzt starten
und ne i3 hochfahren
monkaS
was zum geier ist das
was ist das
die fonts
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass nicht mal basic fonts da drin
wtf
eh
okay wir machen jetzt mal die windows
die windows taktik
starten einfach mal neu
Ach nee, wisst ihr woran das liegt? Das könnte, das könnte tatsächlich an dem scaling liegen.
Das könnte tatsächlich an dem scaling liegen. An dem, an dem, an dem Firmware scaling. Start X.
What? What the fuck? What the hell? Das war so geil.
Das hab ich auch nie gehabt. So für mich sieht das voll normal aus. Das hab ich auch nie gehabt.
Okay, wartet mal, wartet mal. Ich bin ein bisschen, ein bisschen verwirrt, weil das hatte ich, das
hatte ich echt noch nie. Da muss man mal gucken, was das ist. Hab ich irgendwas vergessen zu
installieren? Also Fonts glaub ich nicht, dass es, die Fonts sind, weil wenn es die Fonts gebraucht
hätte, dann hätte das hoffentlich als Abhängigkeit mitgebracht. Okay, so wir löschen das nochmal.
Passwort liegt, fuck. Also hier kann man ja nicht viel ver... Ah, ich glaub, ich weiß woran es liegt.
Ich weiß woran es liegt. Wir müssen noch die Firmware, die Grafikdriver installieren für
Firmware. Wir müssen noch den, den Maus und den Grafikdriver für Firmware installieren und
die Firmware Tools. Die Firmware Tools brauchen wir glaube ich nicht unbedingt, aber dann,
dann wird es auch funktionieren. Oh Gott, DHCP, wat, DHC klein ist es ja auch. So, und jetzt
installieren wir den ganzen Granol auf Firmware. Drei, zwei, eins, zack. So, ich werd jetzt sicher
als halber nochmal rebooten und dann wird es wahrscheinlich funktionieren, hoffe ich mal.
Was wäre eine Linux Installation ohne unerwartete Fehler? True, lolw. So,
jetzt kommt der Moment der Wahrheit. What the fuck? Wollt ihr mich verarschen? What the fuck? Das
hatte ich, das hatte ich noch nie. So, wir machen Accelerate 3D-Grafics, easy. Aber, Leute, Leute.
Leute, ich hab legit keinen plassen Schimmer woran das liegt. Okay, wir müssen, wir müssen
mal Google befragen. Was ist denn, was ist denn der Standard, den man drücken musste?
Okay, alt ist jetzt, oh Scheiße, da stimmt die Fonts fehlend wirklich. Aber warum fehlen
denn die Fonts? Und was für Fonts fehlen da überhaupt? Wir gucken mal. Also, ich hab noch
nie, noch nie Fonts, die Basic Fonts von Hand ins Hand installieren müssen. Was schlagen die
dann vor? Xorg-Utils, Xorg-Utils ist so X-Ice und sowas. Xorg-Utils, okay, wir zählen das mal. Xorg-Font-Utils.
Xorg-Fonts, okay, machen wir. Xorg-Fonts. Sieben, die da. Was ist dein Lieblings-Distro? Zum
Arbeiten, Manjaro, also das hier. Wenn es halt nicht, oh, ernsthaft, das Problem hatte ich noch,
legit hatte ich noch nie im Leben und nie hatte ich dieses Problem. Ich meine, es sieht zwar
absolut reulig schlecht aus jetzt, aber okay. Big Brain Chat, ja. Yes. Windows-Taste als default
modifier, jawoll. Gut. Es sieht zwar mega beschissen aus, aber wir können es noch mal hochskalieren,
weil wir werden jetzt ja auch vor immer Tools und Geschiss-Grammen installieren, dass es dann
ordentliche Auflösung gibt. Aber das hatte ich, mit Fonts hatte ich echt noch nie. Warum nimmst du
denn jetzt die drei Gaps anscheinend? Weil ich die Gaps, weil ich das am Rand ganz praktisch finde
und weil ich es gut finde, wenn man mehrere Terminals nebeneinander hat, dass man sieht,
wo das eine Terminal aufhört und das andere anfängt. Das sieht man durch leichten Gap und ordentliche
Hintergrund sieht man das ganz gut. Okay, also, wir haben jetzt ein i3 drauf, als nächstes müssen
wir gucken, dass wir, dass wir erstmal eine ordentliche Auflösung hinkriegen, also sprich,
dass das, dass das hoch, hoch skaliert. Haben wir vor immer Tools, haben wir schon vor immer Tools
installiert? Wir haben vor immer Tools installiert. Wir haben vor immer Tools noch nicht gestartet.
Wir brauchen noch mal ein Terminal. Irgend eins, von dem ich weiß, dass es auf jeden Fall laufen
wird. Und dann starten wir mal X und gucken, ob ich das Terminal starte. Boah, meine Augen!
Meine Augen, Leute! Das schmerzt, das schmerzt. Ohje. Installieren wir gerade noch mal meine
Manjaro Settings. Da kann ich nämlich Kernel-Versionen, Uhrzeit und Tastatur-Layout einstellen.
So lassen. Manjaro Settings Manager. So, also, Kernel haben wir den richtigen, wir haben den
5, den 5,5er. Keyboard Settings wollen wir nicht Englisch haben, sondern wir wollen German,
ah nee, German. Und zwar German No Dead Keys. Wo gibt's? Ja, das wollen wir haben. Apply. Und
dann Date Time haben wir richtig eingestellt. Set Date Time automatisch ist auch okay, weil
19, doch 19,30 ist vollkommen okay. Quit. Jetzt haben wir hier auch das Richtige. Ja,
wunderbar. Jetzt kann ich den CVX umschalten. So, als nächstes müssen wir Vmware User
starten. Dann sollte er sich eigentlich, nee, wir müssen erst noch Vmware Tools aktivieren.
System CCL, Enable, Vmware, nee wie ist das? Vm Tools? D? Ja. Okay. Und eine Sache, worüber
ich immer wieder stolpere, wenn der Kram nicht funktioniert mit Vmware Tools, es gibt
ein Paket, was nirgendwo erwähnt ist, was man installieren muss. Zumindest der andere
Kram sollte jetzt eigentlich auch funktionieren. Ach nee, ich hab ja gar nicht gestartet.
Ich hab gesagt Enable. Ich muss noch sagen Start. Ah, yes. Guck, jetzt funktioniert
das mit dem Resizer ohne Probleme. Eine Sache, die aber immer, die nirgendwo erwähnt wird,
die aber essentiell ist, dass Copy Paste und manchmal auch das Resizing richtig funktioniert
ist, ist GTKMM. So. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob man die GTK2 beinlegs oder 3er braucht,
wir installieren einfach mal beide. Ansonsten geht Copy Paste nicht. Speaker aus, ja, das
ist jetzt das nächste, was wir machen. So, damit wir diesen nervigen Sound hier wegkriegen.
Also hier, den da. Den da, das erste, was weg muss. Wir machen jetzt die Hardcore-Variante.
Wir installieren jetzt erstmal einen Firefox und wir werden jetzt einfach den Speaker
blacklisten. Nein, wir wollen keine GNU-Default-Fonds, die sehen nämlich reuhig schlecht aus. Wir
wollen... Bitstream Vera wollen wir haben. Das sehen gut. Ich wollte einfach nachher
deine Installation zu machen, ja. So, wir verschieben das schonmal auf den zweiten Desktop
und auf dem ersten Desktop. Ah, Moment, ich hab ja noch gar nichts zum Programm gestartet.
Dem Menu, das installieren wir, ersetzen wir später durch was anderes. So, Firefox. Gut.
Blablabla. Genau, PC, Speaker, da gab's irgendeine Blacklist-Eintrag braucht man da. Genau,
das da muss man machen. So, noch ist er an. Goodbye Speaker. Jetzt der Speaker, der wird
quasi jetzt, das ist die letzte Stufe vor Speaker ausbauen, einfach das Kernel-Modul
nicht laden. Fuck Leute, Speaker aus. Gut, das sieht auch schonmal ganz praktisch aus.
Wir haben einen Browser, wir haben relativ ekliche Schrift, aber gut. So, was wir mal
probieren können, nachdem ich jetzt eine Schriftart installiert habe, wir könnten das Xorg-Font-Misc,
wie hieß das, was ich installiert hab, wir könnten das mal runterschmeißen und gucken,
ob es dann immer noch funktioniert. Ich weiß übrigens nicht genau, wie man J bedient,
ich verwende das normalerweise nicht. Ich benötige das jetzt einfach mal genauso, wie
das andere auch. Okay. Und wenn die Fonts jetzt wieder rumspacken, dann weiß ich, woran
es liegt. Nee, jetzt gehen die Fonts. Jetzt sieht es auch halbwegs ordentlich aus. Okay,
nice. So, jetzt brauchen wir als nächstes einen Gnome-Terminal. Das ist jetzt sehr persönlicher
Geschmack. Es gibt unter Liebungs 50 Millionen Terminal-Programme und jeder mag ein anderes.
Ich hab mich da vor ein paar Jahren mal auf Gnome-Terminal irgendwie festgelegt, ja, und
bisher ging mir noch nicht so sehr auf den Keks an Gnome-Terminal, dass ich was anderes
verwenden wollte. Was verwendet, frage an euch, was verwendet ihr für Terminal-Programme?
Wollen wir die Fedora-Patches? Wir wollen die Fedora-Patches. Das hab ich auch eine
Weile mal verwendet. Terminator, Terminator ist ja mehr oder weniger ein Gnome-Terminal,
das ist ja das gleiche drunter. Xfce-Terminal ist auch mehr oder weniger das gleiche drunter.
Lass mal Lekta-Stream, Leute, Lekta-Stream bei euch. Oh, Monka. Monka-S. Moment, wo ist
es? Ja, ja. Ja, ja, Unity Media.
So, anscheinend wieder zu gehen. Neuladen hilft bei euch, wenn Twitch meint,
das Stream ist offline, bei mir hilft Neuladen natürlich nicht. Also bei euch hilft Neuladen,
wenn der Stream abgekackt ist, dann Twitch. So, ich hab einen Gnome-Terminal drauf und
Gnome-Terminal hat einen, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Bug ist, ehrlich
gesagt, aber die haben irgendwelche Debux-Probleme. Ich weiß nicht genau, woran es liegt, ja.
Deswegen muss man das hier, ach so, erstmal schauen, ob Copy-Paste jetzt ordentlich funktioniert
hier dazwischen. Nein, Copy-Paste geht nicht, aber das da, das da müssen wir jetzt hier
einfügen. Ich schreib das einfach mal aus meiner alten Config ab, dass Gnome-Terminal
richtig funktioniert. Debux-Update-Activation-Environment-Big-Brain, einfach mal so random befehlen, dann funktioniert's.
Guck, wenn ich jetzt nämlich stoppe und wieder starte, und wenn ich mich jetzt nicht verschrieben
hab, dann geht Gnome-Terminal. Und ich hab mich wohl verschrieben, als würde Gnome-Terminal
jetzt funktionieren. Und das muss man, wo hab ich mich denn verknüpft? Debux-Update-Activation.
Hab ich mich nicht verschrieben, oder? Wir gucken jetzt erstmal, dass Copy-Paste ordentlich
funktioniert. Und damit Copy-Paste ordentlich funktioniert, muss man ne Sache machen. Man
muss den Kram hier, Vmware-User, den muss man starten, nachdem der Desktop gestartet
ist. Guck, jetzt funktioniert's nämlich auch. Also, Vmware-User. Weil nachdem der Desktop
gestartet ist, das startet gar nicht nachdem, da gucken wir mal, ob's jetzt funktioniert.
Copy-Paste, Haus-System, geht nicht. Na, Big-Brain, gut gemacht, huge. Wie starten wir das nachdem
der Desktop gestartet ist? Ich mach jetzt mal nen kleinen Bash-Hack, ob das die schönste
Variante ist, das so zu machen. Wir warten einfach zwei Sekunden und starten es dann.
Hab ich mich vielleicht verschrieben? Vmware-User. Also, was das jetzt macht ist, das wartet
zwei Sekunden, im Hintergrund startet den Desktop-Manager, äh, startet den Window-Manager
und dann startet Vmware-User. Das sollte jetzt funktionieren. Big-Brain-Command, ja. Aha,
funktioniert, seht ihr das? Aha, und jetzt kann ich auch den Kram hier vom anderen rüber
kopieren, was ich brauche, um das Gnome-Terminal funktioniert. Äh, das da. Ich hoffe, ich
hab das richtig gemacht, ansonsten Gnome-Terminal. Kann das sein, dass Gnome-Terminal an sich
grad irgendwelche Schmerzen hat? Weil das Gnome-Terminal startet nämlich gar nicht.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht normal. Wir deinstallieren das nochmal, installieren das ohne, was? Hä?
Ach, ich hab das mit den Fedora-Patches installiert. Vielleicht war das doch so keine so gute Idee.
Installieren wir, installieren wir das normale. Nö. What the hell, warum? Das hat gar keinen
Bock. Das will, das will schon mal aus prinziplich. Ähm, da müssen wir jetzt mal wieder eine
Google befragen, weil, ich mein, was wäre so eine Linux-Installation, wenn der Kram auch
ordentlich funktionieren würde? Gnome-Terminal. Was? Das ist ja interessant, das hab ich auch
noch nie gehabt. Was? What the fuck? Ok, das Schöne ist, dass wir einen funktionierenden
Browser haben. Das Schöne ist, dass wir einen funktionierenden, wat? Hat das jetzt
nicht kopiert? Das Schöne ist, dass wir einen funktionierenden Browser haben. Sag mal.
Wenn ich den Kram jetzt mal rüber kopieren kann. Problem mit Gnome-Terminal. Ah, yes.
Bester Antwort. Bei uns ein anderes Terminal. Huge. Was? VTE? Natürlich haben wir VTE installiert.
Warum solltet man VTE nicht installiert haben? Natürlich haben wir das installiert. Wir haben
das offiziell installiert. Das sind so typische Stack-Aufer-Verantworten, ja. Heute trifft
es uns hart, ne? Beide Fehlermeldungen hab ich so noch nie gesehen und gehabt. Ich mein,
ich kann das mal machen, aber das ist eigentlich kompletter Blödsinn, weil wir haben es ja
schon installiert. Yes. Hm. Was hat er denn für Schmerzen? Bester Antwort. Ich benutzt
was anderes, ja. What? Das sollte eigentlich schon eingestellt sein. Ne, Schwachsinn, ne?
Das hier funktioniert auch alles. Die lokalen Settings sind vollkommen in Ordnung. Language
Packs jucken mich jetzt auch nicht wirklich. So, machen wir alles gut. Ich mach mal was
die im Forum schreiben. Mir bleibt da nichts anderes übrig. Ah. So. Muss man das mal so
gut machen? Wahrscheinlich. Wahnsinn. Ja, muss man das mal so gut machen. So, und jetzt
rebooten wir. Und dann kommt mal, ob es funktioniert. Ich hab ja so meine Zweifel, dass es funktioniert.
Oder, bzw. wenn es funktioniert, ist die große Preisfrage, warum das vorher nicht
richtig generiert war. Aber lernt ja nie aus. Ich dachte eigentlich, wir müssen uns nicht
mit so einem Mist aufhalten. Ah, yes. Es geht. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das jetzt war,
wahrscheinlich zu funktionieren. Exzellent. Lull. Sehr schön. Gut, dann können wir ja
weitermachen. Da würde ich vorschlagen, wir machen den ganzen Kram jetzt erst mal temporär
dunkel. Ja, das ist erst mal temporär dunkel. Das hältst du ja so dann aus. Gut, ok, also
jetzt erst mal wieder zurück zum eigentlichen Programm. Wo sind wir eigentlich jetzt genau
stehen geblieben? Den awesome window manager, den hab ich vor 5 Jahren mal ausprobiert.
Also warum das jetzt genau funktioniert hat, ist mir nicht ganz klar, weil diese ganze
language-geschichte und so, die hätte er eigentlich schon ordentlich installiert. Aber gut, was
auch immer. Können wir mal gucken, ob er jetzt hier irgendwas umgestellt hat. Who cares,
wurscht. Stimmt, die Uhrzeit, richtig. Hack installieren, ja, hack, das ist das allerwichtigste,
das stimmt. Erst mal hack installieren. Ne, erst mal network manager installieren. Erst
mal network manager installieren. Erst mal network manager installieren, weil sonst krieg
ich Anfälle. Moment, wo ist nochmal der Text, custom font, hack, das geht erst nachdem
man das Ding beendet hat, ne. Meine Augen. Xterm, Xterm muss wieder weg. Yes. Was ist
hack, ein nicer font. 18, 15, 15, 18, 16, select, so ist schön. So gefällt mir das.
So, das ist mein Lieblingsfont, bester font. So, die menu bar, mach mal weg. Dann machen
wir hier hack auf 15. Jetzt passt das, so ist das gut, perfekt. Jetzt passt das hier unten
nämlich auch schön mit der t-marks bar und alles drin. Wir installieren mal ein Standard
i3-Status, dass wir unten was sehen, dass hier unten nicht diese blöde Fehlermeldung
ist. So. Und jetzt muss ich meinen network manager installieren. Network manager, installieren
network manager, da gibt es auch wieder zig Varianten, was man machen kann. Man kann das
mit networkd machen, man kann das mit dhcpd machen, man kann das mit zig, zig Varianten
sich eine IP-Adresse holen. Ich finde das mit dem network manager aus dem Grund ganz
nice, weil ich, gut jetzt hier im stream weniger, weil er ganz gute Unterstützung für alle
möglichen Sorten von VPN hat und man das auch mit einem klick halt anschalten, ausschalten
sonst was kann. So, also wir installieren den network manager und wir installieren den
connection editor und wir installieren das applet. Wo ist das applet? Ich sehe das applet
irgendwo. NM applet. Applet, wo ist es denn? Da! Keine Ahnung, habe ich gerade nicht gesehen.
So, dass der network manager funktioniert, müssen wir ihn einmal starten und sagen,
dass er bei jedem booten aktiviert werden soll. Ich glaube das Ding hieß einfach network
manager. Nee, oh, network. Wie hieß das Ding? Ah, großgeschrieben. Manche mögen groß und
klein schreiben, weil man weiß es nicht. So, jetzt haben wir unten nämlich auch die Sache
für unser Netzwerkzeug. Das funktioniert jetzt nicht. Was geht mir da Musik ab? Ah,
wir haben das Ding nämlich nicht gestartet. Start. Sehr gut. So, jetzt schmeiße ich das
Ding. Ich starte einmal neu, um zu gucken, ob das jetzt auch alles funktioniert. Oh fuck,
ich habe vergessen die dhcp-geschichte einzurichten. Wahrscheinlich funktioniert es jetzt trotzdem
nicht. Hat es jetzt der IP geholt? Ja, nice, funktioniert. Anscheinend hat es standardmäßig
drin. Ja. Gut, jetzt kriegen wir nämlich automatisch eine IP beim starten. Das ist doch schonmal
nice. IP leak. O-M-F-G. Die IP ist geleaked. So, also was machen wir jetzt als nächstes
schönes? Wir haben einen browser und einen terminator funktioniert. Wir brauchen erstmal
ein Programm und ein ordentliches grafisches theme zu setzen. Das ist jetzt nicht so merkwürdig
aus, wie wir. Dann installieren wir uns noch einen chrome, weil unter zwei browsers funktioniert
natürlich bekannterweise nichts. Das verschieben wir mal auf desktop 2. Auf desktop 1 starten
wir mal, nachdem er installiert ist, einen chrome. Ich habe eigentlich immer firefox
und chrome drauf. Eine IDE, das waren wir dann. Da brauchen wir noch ein bisschen für. Nein,
nicht chrome driver, chrome. Sehr gut, funktioniert. Nein, ich will das nicht bookmarken. Gut,
jetzt gehen wir mal als erstes in unsere, jetzt müssen wir erstmal hier die bar ausplanten.
Die geht man nämlich auf den kicks. Wir müssen mal mal scrolling. Wir brauchen die scrollbar
muss weg. Und die menu bar muss weg. Gut. Dann müssen wir in unsere i3-config und müssen
ein paar gaps einstellen. Da tue ich jetzt gar nicht so, als müsste ich das aus dem
Kopf. Das gucke ich mir einfach ab von der anderen konfig von mir. Ah nee, fuck, die
habe ich gar nicht eingesteckt, oder? Oh no, die habe ich gar nicht eingesteckt. Na gut,
da muss ich doch gucken. I3-gaps-example-config. Genau, smart-gaps verwenden wir nicht. Aus
0 in 5 habe ich immer. Was das macht ist, man sieht es jetzt nicht so richtig. Das sorgt
dafür, dass man leichte Lücken zwischen den unterschiedlichen Fenstern hat. So, und jetzt
muss ich noch den window-border ausschalten. So, so ist das doch schick. Und man erkennt
es. So, was wir jetzt noch machen müssen, ist ein Hintergrundbild setzen. Und ich habe
da ein neues Skript irgendwo. Und zwar, das downloaded immer den, das habe ich auf GitHub
gefunden, ist aber relativ simpel, ich zeige es euch mal. Das downloaded immer das aktuelle
big image of the day. Wir machen zwar einen repos-ordner. Nachdem ich, ich kann den kram
jetzt auch mal auf GitHub hochladen, nachdem ich im stream immer öfters Leute frage, hier,
habe ich meine config irgendwo. Vielleicht machen wir jetzt einfach mal ein git-repo
mit den configs drinnen. So, get, das ist nicht von mir, wie gesagt. Das habe ich irgendwo
auf GitHub gefunden. Es ist aber ziemlich simpel. Der zieht sich das aktuelle image
of the day von Bing, dann passt er das xml nach dem eigentlichen fahrt zum image und
lädt dann die 1080p variante runter. Easy. Eats. Easy. So. Und dann brauchen wir bloß
noch hier den image, background und sonst was, manager installieren. Und dann sollte
der uns jetzt, wenn das funktioniert und wir den kram installiert haben, sollte er uns
jetzt den aktuellen image, den aktuellen Bing of the day image als Hintergrund setzen.
Kennst du Stow? Das habe ich mir auch vor einer ganzen Weile mal angeguckt, ja. Es
gibt ja noch mehr, da gibt es doch irgendwie My Castle oder so als Dot-File-Management,
gibt es da ein paar Sachen. So, mal gucken, ob es funktioniert. Get Wallpaper. Zack. Endlich.
Excellent Wallpaper. Huge. Very nice. Also dafür ist Bing tatsächlich ganz gut. Für
Wallpaper. Das ist auch das einzige, was für Bing richtig gut ist. Ja. Ehrlich gesagt
verwende ich Bing auch für sonst nichts großartiges. Wir gehen nochmal in die E3-Config und stellen
den font ein auf, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das so ging. Hack. Ja. Hack 12. So ist
doch gut. So gefällt mir das ganze. Ich lösche mal hier ein bisschen Kram raus aus der Konfig,
das wird so unübersichtlich. Z-Font. Blah. E3-Log braucht kein Mensch. Network-Manager
startet automatisch, das ist schön. Den ganzen Krempel brauchen wir nicht, das ist zum Lautstärke
ändern. Das können wir die fort lassen, das können wir auch die fort lassen. Das ist
die Tastenkombination, die man drücken muss, um Fenster zuzumachen. Demenu lassen wir erstmal
drinnen. Das werden wir später noch ersetzen. Standard Keybindings lassen wir auch drinnen.
Standard Desktops lassen wir auch erstmal drinnen. Ja. Das ist erstmal ok so. Wer wirst
du durch den Font zum Hacker? Zumindest kannst du anderen, die auch keine Ahnung haben, zeigen,
dass du ein krasser Hacker-Man bist. Die denken, als wenn die das sehen, dass du Hack als Font
hast, dann ist es eigentlich schon vorbei. Ich kann sagen, meine Güte, was ein krasser
Hacker-Man ist. Mit Kali oder Tails kannst du Hacker-Man sein. Sonst wird es eng. Mein
Chrome-Browser ist gerade abgekackt. Chat, ich seh euch nicht mehr. Jetzt bin ich ja
wieder da. Wir brauchen jetzt noch ein ordentliches Farbschema für unsere Konsole, weil das sieht
kacke aus. Wir können doch machen curl parrot.live, allerwichtigste Programm. Ohne das geht gar
nichts. Erste Funktion. Allerwichtigste Funktion, muss man eigentlich sagen. So, dann installieren
wir noch mal hier EXA und FD. Das ist ein LS-Ersatz, der von Haus aus deutlich schöner
aussieht. Also LS sieht so aus und das sieht so aus. Das ist schon gleich viel, viel nicer.
Also, find ich jetzt. Viel nicer. Wir machen erstmal einen ordentlichen Terminal-Theme.
Und ich mag eigentlich den Kram hier ganz gern. Ich nehm immer entweder 80s oder Tomorrow
Night. Gefällt mir am besten. Was machen wir hier ins Repo? Wie ging das nochmal mit Submodules?
Geht Submodule, ich hab keine Autovervollschuldigung. Submodule add. So, ne. Ah, yes. Machs doch abhängig
vom Hintergrundbild. Ne, ich hab gern meine Shell. Ich kenn das. Das ist wirklich cool.
Das generiert aus dem Hintergrundbild nen Color Schema für die Konsole. Man sieht quasi
Hintergrundbild und Konsole ähnlich aus. Aber ich mag, wenn meine Konsole wirklich immer
gleich aussieht. Base 16, Shell, Scripts. Und da wollen wir Base 16, Tomorrow. Tomorrow
Night wollen wir haben. SH. Ah, yes. Excellent. So mag ich das. So gefällt mir das. Das ist
Geschmackssache. Wie gesagt, also, das ist ziemlich individuell, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Gut, dann installieren wir uns jetzt zsh. Zeit von unserer Bash ist gekommen. Und bevor
wir das Ganze starten, machen wir hier ne zshrc und die verlinken wir ins Heimatverzeichnis,
dass sie direkt greift, bevor wir das Ganze starten. So, also, ln, repos.files nach dahin.
So, wenn wir jetzt hier gucken, haben wir hier ne zshrc. Und da können wir jetzt unsere
ganzen Config-Geschichten reinschreiben. Unter anderem, dass er das am Anfang sourcen
wird, was die Shell auch gleich ordentlich aussieht. Moin, jeen, wal, jeen, 80. Krass,
nächst, da mehr Hacker-Mans sind am Start. Ok, gucken wir mal. Zsh starten. Ah, ich bin
hier auch ein Kacknup. Der hat auch den Pfad vergessen. So, funktioniert das Ganze nämlich
auch. Ok, zack. Bam. Gut, was wir jetzt noch machen müssen, ist den Prompt anpassen. Weil
den Prompt mag ich so überhaupt nicht. Poggers. Ich mein, natürlich ist es schon mal sehr
gut, dass da Poggers steht. Schon mal besser als jedes andere Zeichen. Aber es sieht trotzdem
ziemlich doof aus, kann man sagen. Wenn man nach T-Mas auch startet, siehts dümmer aus.
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal machen, change shell. Und zwar, oh Gott, wie hat das noch
funktioniert. Ich guck ganz einfach. Weiß gar nicht, ob man da das Parameter angeben
muss. Ah, hier. Minus S. Das hat nämlich den Vorteil, dass wenn wir uns jetzt hier ausloggen,
ich glaub wir müssen uns komplett ausloggen, dann haben wir jetzt unsere Shell zum Einloggen.
Ist jetzt direkt zsh. Und bash ist erstmal rip. Firefox starten, Terminal starten. Und
das sieht doch jetzt schon mal ganz gut aus. Jetzt, als nächstes, machen wir den Prompt
noch ein bisschen hübsch. Und ich werde jetzt keine großartigen zsh-plugin-manager-plugin-sammlung
sonst was ins Leben. Wir machen jetzt wirklich nur mal so die basic Geschichte, dass man
die Shell schön benutzen kann, weil das eine sehr individuelle Sache ist. Der eine mag
auto-completion-plugins, der andere mag Syntax-highlighting-plugins, der eine mag den plugin-manager, der andere mag den plugin-manager.
Vollkommen wurscht. Das muss ihr am Endeffekt wirklich gucken, wie ihr das mag. Ich mach
jetzt so, dass ich das ganz gut benutzen könnte. Also was ich als Prompt immer gerne verwende
ist das da. Das da. Der gefällt mir am besten von allen Prompts. Oh my zsh ist was das magisch
überhaupt nicht. Da ist mir zu viel, da ist mir schon zu viel Kram dabei. So. Pure Prompt.
Oh das ist Wind Waker. Pretzto habe ich normalerweise immer verwendet. Aber ich bin jetzt auch da
ein bisschen von weggekommen. Hier, das muss man da reinschreiben. Pretzto hatte ich hier
in der anderen. Ist noch. Die VM die wir normalerweise immer verwenden, das ist Pretzto. Aber ich
bin jetzt ein bisschen von weggekommen, weil da ist auch wieder so viel Zeug dabei. Ich
verwende vielleicht 5 Sachen davon. Und ich bin jetzt auch auf meinem Notebook auf der
Arbeit dazu übergegangen, dass ich die paar Sachen die ich brauche mir selbst einrichte
und gut ist. Irgendwie habe ich das jetzt doppelt gemacht. So. Eine Sache die wir noch
machen, wir legen eine Vim AC an. Die legen wir aber übrigens in dort an. Wir legen eine
Vim AC rein und da sagen wir set Maus und Syntax on. Weil der standardmäßig Mausunterstützung
an hat. Weiß nicht warum man einen Vim mit standardmäßiger Mausunterstützung macht.
Aber man Charo dachte das ist eine gute Idee. Wenn wir jetzt die Vim AC aufmachen sehen
wir haben keine Mausunterstützung mehr. So muss das sein. Agerion25 hat abonniert für
zwei Monate. Huge Sub. Hast du schon mal Vimium gearbeitet in Chrome? Nee Vimium hatte ich
nicht. Ich hatte, wie heißt das? Vroom oder so? Vroom? Vroom hatte ich vor einer Weile
mal. Aber ich bin für mich zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass Vim Shortcuts im Browser nur
teilweise nützlich sind. Auch die Navigation über die Tastatur mit Links ist nicht mein
Fall. Also ich bin für mich zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass man einen Browser und moderne
Webseiten tatsächlich am besten mit der Tastatur bedient. So und jetzt haben wir hier einen
ordentlichen, ordentlichen Prompt, der auch ganz schick aussieht. Ähm. Jetzt copy paste
ich mir mal was aus meiner anderen ZSHRC. Nämlich einen kleinen Wrapper für EXA, dass
ich das verwenden kann wie LS. Das habe ich mir irgendwann mal zusammen gewusstet. Und
eine andere Sache. Nee, das machen wir später. Weil jetzt kann ich LS machen und er ruft
EXA auf. Und obwohl es manche Parameter nicht gibt. Feifers Block kann man Vimium navigieren.
Ja gut Feifers Block ist ja auch an nicht gestyled kaum zu überbieten noch. Da ist
ja kaum was, was nicht funktionieren kann. Aber wie gesagt, also für mich bin ich zum
Schluss gekommen, man bedient einfach moderne Webseiten am besten mit Maus. Es ist nicht
verkehrt, wenn man ein Wimplugin hat, wo man dann vielleicht jetzt sagen kann, ok, ich
brauche jetzt mal hier diesen Link und ich drücke dann F. Ich glaube F ist standardmäßig
für Links, Follow und oder O. Entweder F oder O, eins vor beiden. Und dann kann ich
dann hier den Link anklicken. Aber ich bin jetzt mittlerweile der Ansicht, dass mit Maus
fährt man immer noch am besten. Unser Hintergrundbild hat übrigens nicht funktioniert. Und das
kommt manchmal vor, weil Bing hat ein Rate Limit. Und wenn man Get Wallpapers zu oft
aufruft, dann sagt Bing, du hast doch schon die letzten fünf Minuten dreimal den Wallpaper
abgerufen und blockt ein. Das heißt, wenn man wirklich innerhalb von fünf Minuten fünfmal
rebooted, dann kann es sein, dass der Bing Wallpaper nicht immer funktioniert. Aber normalerweise
reboot man ja auch nicht so oft. So, weiter geht's im Text. Wir brauchen jetzt noch ein
ordentliches Icon-Theme. Habt ihr da Vorschläge? Also, was wir jetzt machen, ist, wir inszenieren
zwar ein ordentliches Icon-Theme, weil das standardmäßige sieht echt hässlich aus.
Ich meine, es sieht nicht Windows 95 eklig aus, aber schön ist es nicht. Mir gefallen
die Standard-Gnome-Icons nicht. Standardmäßig ist halt auch nur das Standard-Gnome-Gnome-Zeug
drauf. Was wir aber schon mal machen können, ist, wir können in die Config für GTK-Anwendungen
gehen, die irgendwie nicht da ist, wahrscheinlich, weil ich nichts geändert habe, und können
die Icons einschalten. Okay, was für einen Icon-Theme nehmen wir dann? Was hab ich denn
normalerweise immer? Ich glaube, Paper. Ich glaube, Paper-Icons oder so hab ich sonst
immer. Ja, Paper. Die Paper-Icons hab ich normalerweise, glaub, immer. Papieros gefällt
mir nicht. Aber ich kann's mal erzählen. Wir können uns ja einfach mal angucken. Ich
glaub, das ist das, was ich normalerweise immer hab. Papieros gefällt mir normalerweise.
Ich glaube, dass es das ist, was ich jetzt im Kopf hab. Das war nicht so meins. Aber,
was Papieros mit Papieros-Folder? Aha, okay. Papieros-Icon-Theme. Können wir uns gleich
mal angucken? So, Icon-Theme. Papieros haben wir. Ach nee, Paper. Genau, die hab ich, glaub,
normalerweise. Paper hab ich immer. So, Papieros gefällt mir nicht, weil, ich kann's euch
ja gleich mal zeigen, warum man Papieros nicht gefällt, falls es das ist. Ähm, ach so. Moment.
Moment. Config-GTK. Man muss hier erstmal, das ist wieder so typisches Linux-Gekram,
warum muss man die Menü-Icons erstmal von Hand einschalten? Warum ist das überhaupt
standardmäßig, warum sind die Menü-Icons überhaupt standardmäßig aus? The fuck? But
why? Man weiß es nicht. Die wollen, dass nur Big-Brain-Leute Menü-Icons haben, weil
ja auch gerade die Pros Menü-Icons brauchen. Ah, Zoial. Twitch Prime. Dankeschön. High
IQ-Sub. So, was mir an Papieros nicht gefällt persönlich ist, dass die ganzen Icons schwarz
sind. Also, die sind kaum zu unterscheiden hier. Jetzt Chat. Ich weiß, was ihr schreiben
wollt, Chat. Ihr wisst, dass es so nicht gemeint war. Also, reißt euch zusammen, ja? Ich sag's
so schon vorher, aber. Also, mir gefällt nicht, dass die ganzen Menü-Icons so gleich aussehen.
Deswegen, glaub ich, war das bei den Papieros-Icons, sah das besser aus. Äh, bei den Paper-Icons
sah das, glaub ich, besser aus. Ja. Ihh, warum haben die Paper-Icons keinen Vorwärts- und
Zurück-Knopf? What the fuck, wo ist denn der hin? Wo ist der Vorwärts- und Zurückwärts-Knopf
hin? Linux in 2020. Ja, ich mag einfarbige Menü-Icons nicht. Wir machen jetzt, wir installieren
jetzt China. Nee, komm, das geht immer. Wir installieren die Elementary-Icons. Die sehen
ganz gut aus. Die sehen eigentlich ganz gut aus. Die kann man immer nehmen. Die Elementary-Icons,
die sehen ganz gut aus. Die kann man, das passt. So. Huge. Warum XFCE und nicht Mate?
Das ist weder XFCE noch Mate. Oder was meinste? Ist ein integrierter Nuke-Filter mit den Icons.
Ja, ey, mich würd's nicht wundern. Es sind so viele Linux-Bros und auch Leute, wenn ich
mir da manche Messages in Mail-Listen und auf GitHub-Issues angucke, die sind so Anti-Noop,
Anti-Casual-Benutzer, dass man sich wirklich nicht wundern muss, dass den Kram erstens
kaum einer benutzen will auf dem Desktop und zweitens die Unterstützung so schlecht ist.
So, wir müssen uns mal übrigens die T-Max-Conf anlegen und die grüne Leiste da unten mal
ändern. Die grüne Leiste gefällt mir überhaupt nicht. Aber dieses Jahr wird das Jahr des
Linux-Desk haupt. Natürlich, natürlich, was sonst. Ich paste mal einen ganz kleinen Teil
von meiner T-Max-Config rein. Nämlich, was die Leiste dort ein bisschen stylt. Das sieht
viel angenehmer aus. Und eine wichtige Sache brauchen wir noch. Wer das noch nicht kennt,
die ganzen Terminals aus Linux können mittlerweile 32-bit Farben, also 24-bit Farben, also True
Color Test. So, da gab es nämlich einen schönen Test für das da. So, und wie man hier sieht
ist, funktioniert es nicht. Man sieht, die Abstufungen sind viel zu grob. Wenn ich die
ohne T-Max ausführe, dann sieht es gut aus. Man sieht ja hier den Unterschied dazwischen.
Also, hier ist es halt hässlich und hier sieht es halt gut aus. Das heißt, man muss
jetzt erst noch mal in T-Max die Unterstützung hinzufügen für True Color, also 24-bit Farbtiefe.
Das muss alles ein bisschen obskur und kompliziert sein, sonst mögen das die Leute unter Linux
nicht. So, und wenn ich diesen Parameter jetzt hier hinzugefügt habe, dann haben wir auch
True Color in T-Max. Die Bonuslevel von Mario 3D World. Boah, das ist ja schon ewig her,
wo wir das zu dritt gespielt haben. Ich habe vom Mastercrubber irgendwie drei Jahre nichts
mehr, ne das stimmt nicht. Ich war mit dem in Frankfurt mal futtern vor einem Jahr oder
so. Aber sonst habe ich vom Casten wirklich lange nichts mehr gehört. Vom Fabian, mit
dem habe ich ab und zu zwischendurch Kontakt, aber der spielt ja gerade Browser Games und
hat mich auch nicht großartig Bock auf YouTube und sonstige Sachen. Aber jetzt sieht das
Ganze jedoch schon mal relativ hübsch und gut aus. Das heißt, jetzt können wir dazu
übergehen, mal ein bisschen Zeug zu installieren, was wir brauchen, um Sachen zu entwickeln,
würde ich sagen. Oder ich überlege, brauchen wir sonst noch was? Browser Games. Ja, der
Fabian spielt Mobile, nicht Browser Games. Sorry, nicht Browser Games. Mobile Games.
Ein GTK Theme. Eigentlich finde ich das Standard Theme vollkommen in Ordnung. Ich frage mich
nur, kann man das Standard Theme nicht irgendwie auf dunkel machen? Raid Shadow Legends, ja.
Eye Dark Trooper, Twitch Prime. Dankeschön für den Sub, huge Sub. So, das ist doch jetzt
schon mal ganz gut nutzbar. Also, dann installieren wir uns mal die JetBrains Toolbox. Lassen
wir mal ein paar ordnen, dass wir mal unsere... Wir müssen, Leute, es tut mir ja in der Seele
weh jedes Mal an der Stelle, aber, dass der Kram läuft, wir müssen Java installieren,
es geht nicht anders. Das Zeug läuft nicht ohne Java. Es geht leider nicht anders. Ja,
ich weiß, Pains Champ, es tut weh, es tut weh. In der GTK, in die GTK Application, Prefer
installiert. Kann man gleich mal ausprobieren. Während es hier mal durch ist. Ähm, ich
glaube jetzt, nee, nee, du kannst ja alles mögliche erfassen. Im Chat steht es ja hier
zumindest auf Twitch noch frei, was er schreibt. Du fandest ja Modern Warfare das neue, nicht
das alte ganz gut. Hast du Warzone mal gespielt? Nee. Und ich muss sagen, ich fand Modern Warfare
auch nur in der Beta und noch nicht mal die ganze Beta ganz gut. Mir ging es am Ende der
Sache schon so hart auf den Sack. Es gibt ja bis heute keine offizielle Stellungnahme,
was Skill-Based-Matchmaking angeht. Die sagen ja quasi, so nach dem Auto, die tun so, als
würde das nicht existieren. Okay, also was müssen wir hier reinschreiben? Prefer Dark
Theme. Prefer Dark Theme. Okay, mal gucken, was jetzt passiert. Aha! Pog Eris. Habt ihr
das gesehen hier? Schon ist es gedarksteamed. So, dann installieren wir erst mal ein Notizprogramm.
Das benutze ich eigentlich auch immer. Äh, Brüssel Studio Code brauchen wir da noch.
Wir brauchen noch ein paar Sachen. Äh, i3-Status Rust brauchen wir noch. Git, Git haben wir
auch schon installiert. Rofi, Rofi müssen wir noch installieren. Ja, genau. Wir können
aber hier nebenbei, ähm, mal unsere IDE installieren. Accept. Und zwar einmal Rider und einmal
Go-Land. Kann er nebenbei machen. Dann müssen wir noch die Status Bar anpassen, dass die
oben hinkommt und nicht unten. Gibt noch ein paar Dinge, die wir machen müssen. I3-Status
RS. Ja, drei. Ich nehme, wenn es geht, mittlerweile immer die Binary Releases, einfach weil ich
keinen Bock habe, das selbst zu kompilieren und fünf Minuten in meinem Paketmanager zu
gucken, bis es fertig kompiliert ist. So, die Config für die Status-Leiste hier unten,
die mache ich jetzt nicht selbst. Oh, ganz wichtig, Leute. Ich habe, wir haben, wir haben
das Elementarste vergessen. Wir haben, wir haben das Wichtigste vergessen. Wir haben
Emoji Support fürs Terminal vergessen. Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen? Emoji Support fürs
Terminal ist nicht dabei. Das geht aber nicht. So geht's nicht. Das müssen wir gleich ändern.
JoyPixels, erstmal Emoji-Font installieren. JoyPixels, yes. JoyPixels ist der hier. Das
ist der, der ehemals Emoji 1 war. Oh, die sind eigentlich ganz hübsch. Die sind eigentlich
ganz hübsch. Ich mag den JoyPixels-Font. Am liebsten, am liebsten hätte ich ja Twitter-Emojis,
allerdings hat noch keiner Twitter-Emoji, einen Twitter-Emoji-Font gemacht, der unter
Verlilungs funktioniert. Leider. Aber wenn wir jetzt hier gucken. Ah, ich glaube, wir
müssen neu starten, dass das Ganze funktioniert. Ich glaube, okay, Reboot müssen wir nicht.
Das reicht wahrscheinlich, wenn wir den Desktop neu starten. Danke für den Tipp. Ja, schön.
Ich finde immer gut, wenn hier ein bisschen was bei rumkommt für alle. So, und jetzt
sollten wir Emojis haben. Ihh, es ist ja mal ein Firefox auch schwarz. Aha, Leute, Katastrophe
abgewendet. Emojis im Terminal. Beste. Jetzt nochmal Glück gehabt. Also, das ist jetzt
echt knapp der Katastrophe entgangen. Ganz knapp, ganz knapp. Ah, yes. Ja, das ist
echt knapp. Ah, yes. Excellent. So muss das sein. Gut. Jetzt habe ich euch genug gequält
mit ein paar Emojis. Ach so, ja, geht da Kackhaufen auch. Na klar, da war doch jeder
bei. Wo ist er? Habe ich den nicht mitcopy pasted? Ah doch, da ist er doch. Da ist doch
einer Kackhaufen hier, da. Ganz links. Oh, den einen kennt er nicht. So, was wir jetzt
noch machen müssen, ihr seht jetzt, ich bin ja immer ein Fan davon, wenn alles einheitlich
aussieht. Das Problem ist jetzt, dass der Firefox, dass der Firefox standardmäßig die
eingebauten Emojis verwendet. Wenn man das überschreiben will, muss man Sachen umlinken,
dass die das verwenden. So, da muss ich aber mal selbst Google bemühen, wie das nochmal
funktioniert hat. Und zwar Firefox Joypixels, da gibt es bestimmt einen Eintrag für. How
to apply Joypixels, genau. Nein, das da, genau, das muss man machen. Das schöne ist, dass
mittlerweile für alles in den Stack Overflow Eintrag existiert. So, danach muss man den
Fontcache erneuern. Und wenn wir jetzt den Firefox stoppen und den Firefox wieder starten
und auf den Emojis gehen, dann haben wir hier auch unsere schönen Joypixels und nicht
mehr die Bild-in-Emojis. Jetzt können wir uns freuen. Wir können froh locken, wie so
schön heißt, können wir jetzt. Weil wir überall die gleichen Emojis haben. Poggers. So. Urschl
Studio Code brauchen wir noch. Als nächstes mache ich mal diese hässliche, diese hässliche
Leiste hier unten weg. Die ist eklig. Und wir wollen die Leiste ja auch transparent
haben, deswegen müssen wir noch einen Composite Manager installieren, der Transparenz kann.
Dann nehmen wir PCOM. So, PCOM, wie oft ich... Wenn man den standardmäßig startet, markerlich,
ok, BackendXRender war das, glaube ich, ja. Also, der hat jetzt standardmäßig so ziemlich
ekliges Fading drinnen, das sackt. Ich finde das nicht schön, dieses Faden. Deswegen können
wir eine, eine PCOM-Config, ich weiß nicht, wo die hin muss. Ja. Ja. Und da können wir
reinschreiben. Fading gleich false. Und dann fadet er auch nicht mehr. Guck, dann. Kann
das sein, dass der an der Stelle nicht guckt? Wann bist du fertig? Aber das wird noch ein
bisschen dauern, bis das wirklich so ist, dass ich sagen kann, ja, jetzt habe ich erstmal
alles soweit, soweit eingerichtet. Muss da, guckt er vielleicht danach? Oh nee. In TMAX
funktioniert Vor- und Zurück-Taste standardmäßig nicht in ZSH. STBBA42. Da kann ich euch aber
zeigen, was man dagegen machen kann. Das werden wir gleich fixen. So. Und da brauchen wir
jetzt eine PCOM-Config. Fading gleich false. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass es Fading
gleich false war. PCOM. Ah, guckt, jetzt haben wir kein Fading mehr. Was sind die wichtigsten
TMAX-Shortcuts? Neues, gesplittetes Tab. Prozent, neues hochkant, hochkantgedingstes Tab. File-Tasten
für wechseln. Ah ja, ein ganz wichtiges TMAX-Shortcut ist, mal angenommen, man hat hier was laufen.
Ja, also mal angenommen, man hat hier, man hat hier was laufen. Und, ähm. Oh fuck. Ich
kann aber abbremsen. Ah nee, ich bin im falschen, ich bin im falschen Fenster drin. Ich hab irgendwie
kein Highlighting für die Fenster, kann das sein? Ich hab kein Highlighting, welches Fenster
aktiv ist, das ist ziemlich fail. Na gut, nichtsdestotrotz, mal angenommen, ähm. Ich bin jetzt hier
drin und hab Harptop laufen und das ist mir zu klein und ich seh nicht alles. Dann sag
ich ähm, Z und dann maximiert das das ganze. Mit noch mal Z machts wieder klein. Das ist
äußerst praktisch. Was haben wir da eigentlich gerade für exquisite Musik laufen im Hintergrund?
Excellent. Ah, yes. Oh, oh, oh, oh, Leute. Ich glaube, das war keine gute Idee mit dem
massenhaften Emoji-Spam. Das macht das Terminal ein bisschen kaputt. Oh, die T-Mark Session
hängt. RIP. Ah, fuck, Alter. Kill all, minus 9, T-Marks. What? Das muss weg. Ja. Bam, bam,
bam. So. Ah, yes. Excellent. Äh, benutzt du ein T-Marks Preset? Nee. Äh, ich hab nur
ein paar Farben rüber kopiert aus meiner eigentlich normalen Config. Und ich check das auch alles
ein und machs dann auf GitHub. Oh, die T-Marks Conf haben wir ja gar nicht verlinkt. Dann
kopieren wir die T-Marks Conf mal rüber hier. Repos,.files, T-Marks Conf, löschen die
T-Marks Conf und verlinken den Kram. So. Sehr gut. Excellent. Da ist, wie gesagt, da ist
noch nicht viel drinnen in der... Ups. Das war jetzt sehr schlau, Max. Da ist noch nicht
viel drinnen in der T-Marks Conf. Ähm. Außer, dass, ähm, dass da True Color kann. Also
24 Bit Farbtiefe. Und ein bisschen Farbe. Und das History Limit. Ich vermute mal, dass
das History Limit uns, äh, gerade das bisschen... Du benutzt gerade Yadam.io. Was ist denn das?
Ach,.files Manager. Ja, da hatten wir wohl schon ein paar Vorschläge zu. Kümmerst du
dich eigentlich jemals wieder um den Versandtracker? Boah, ich weiß nicht. Ich hab grad so viel
Zeug zu tun, auch so viel Kram zu programmieren. Ähm, ich weiß nicht, ob ich, äh, erstens
Bock drauf habe und in nächster Zeit mal wieder zum Versandtracker komme. Ich weiß, dass
der nicht fertig ist, der Versandtracker. Da fehlt Amazon noch. Und, ähm, ein paar
andere Sachen sind auch noch nicht schön. Wir machen die Musik mal wieder an. Die Nintendo-
Musik hat mir eigentlich ziemlich gut gefallen, ja. Einfach nochmal laufen. So, aber jetzt
müssen wir noch eine Sache machen. Also, was ist... Sagt sich jetzt so einfach. Was ist
denn der Versandtracker? Ich hab mal was gebastelt. Und zwar ein Programm, um von unterschiedlichen
Transportdienstleister quasi in einer Oberfläche darstellen zu lassen, dass man sich darstellen
lassen kann, wo dann ein Paket gerade ist. Ja, so ein bisschen mit Karte und Gedöns. Der
unterstützt aktuell DHL, Hermes, DPD, UPS. Amazon wollte ich noch einbauen. Amazon hab
ich noch nicht eingebaut. Amazon ist ein bisschen kompliziert. Und das Coole daran ist, dass
du die Tracking-Nummern nicht von Hand pflegen musst, sondern der guckt in deinem E-Mail-Postfach
nach, ob er Mails findet mit, ähm, Tracking-Nummern drinnen. Und wenn er Mails mit Tracking-Nummern
findet oder wenn er Mails findet mit Zahlen, die so aussehen, als könnten sie Tracking-Nummern
sein, dann guckt er noch, ob in der gleichen Mail der Name des jeweiligen Transportdienstleisters
drinnen steht. Und wenn das der Fall ist, dann prüft er, ob es diese Versandnummer gibt
beim jeweiligen Transportdienstleister und dann editest die automatischen Webinterfaces,
wo du nachgucken kannst. Eigentlich ziemlich cooles Projekt gewesen, aber man sieht schon,
ich hab da fast ein Jahr nichts mehr dran gemacht. Probier mal Janem.io. Ähm, es kam
heute schon ein paar Dot-File-Manager. Ähm, ich guck mir das vielleicht nächstes Mal
an. Aber jetzt heute, heute nicht. Äh, was soll das eigentlich mit der 1-Center-Duel?
Dazu haben wir ein Kommando im Chat. Ich glaub, Ausrufezeichen 1. Ausgeschrieben 1. Okay.
Also, wir kümmern uns jetzt erstmal darum, dass wir PCOM starten. Backend, Backend X-Render.
So, und wir machen jetzt die, ähm, die Leiste hier unten transparent und schön. Und zwar
machen wir dazu eine, ähm, E3-Status-RS-Conf. Oh, hab ich das richtig geschrieben, Leute?
Hab ich das richtig geschrieben? Nein, hab ich nicht richtig geschrieben. E3-Status-RS-Conf.
Und da bin ich jetzt wirklich mal faul an der Stelle. Und zwar nehme ich einfach meine
aktuelle. Ich cheate quasi. So. Ähm, jetzt müssen wir das Ganze noch in unsere E3-Config
eintragen. Und zwar anstatt der normalen Status-Bar muss da E3-Status rein. Und da
müssen wir auf GitHub gucken, wie das aussieht. Ja, so. Ja, yes. Äh, Status-Command E3-Status-RS
ist korrekt. Pass to zur Config ist, äh,.i3-Status-RS.conf. Exzellent. Hä? Da ist sie. Sieht doch schon
gleich viel schöner aus. Sieht doch gleich viel viel schöner aus als vorher. Jetzt müssen
wir den Kram nur noch transparent kriegen. Und um den Kram transparent zu kriegen, muss
man, glaube ich, den Background auf Null schalten. Null stellen. Ja. Bäm. Natürlich ist das
meine Meinung. Weil ich es ja auch einrichte. Das Ganze ist sehr subjektiv. Sei es auch
was für ein Terminal-Programm man verwendet, was man für ein Farbschema verwendet, was
man überhaupt für ein Programm verwendet. Das ist alles äußerst subjektiv. So, da
ist dann immer noch mal eine Feind-Alternative, die ich in letzter Zeit mich versuche, dran
zu gewöhnen, um Sachen schneller zu finden. Da kann man zum Beispiel sagen fd, ähm, t-marks
oder.t-marks. Das funktioniert nicht. Weil er anscheinend standardmäßig nix Verstecktes
sucht. Wallpaper findet er aber. Kannst du den Versand-Tracker mal verlinken, X? Geh
einfach auf Git, mach mal Ausrufezeichen Git oder so. Da müsstest du den Link zu meinem
GitHub-Account finden und da ist dann auch der Versand-Tracker drunter. Und jede Menge
anderes unfertiges Zeug. Hab ich eigentlich jemals was fertig gemacht hier? So, ok, also
lass mal weiter überlegen. Achso, natürlich, ich muss es ja hier noch reinschreiben mit
dem Get-Wallpaper. Ich hab das mit dem Wallpaper hier gar nicht reingeschrieben, das wird
kein Wunder, dass das nicht funktioniert beim Starten. Oh, Get-Wallpaper. Vmware-User starten
wir, PCOM starten wir. Gut, stoppen wir mal und gucken, ob das jetzt alles schön funktioniert.
Start X. Ah, fast. Warum wird der Hintergrund nicht transparent? Warum wird der Hintergrund
nicht transparent? Hab ich irgendwas falsch gemacht? Eben wurde der Hintergrund doch transparent
oder hab ich mich verguckt? War der Hintergrund eben transparent hier oder war der nie transparent?
Ich gucke einfach ab, ich gucke einfach ab. Wir cheaten jetzt einfach mal. Der war immer
schon schwarz, ok. Also Chat, ich muss doch sehr bitten. Wir gucken uns das Ganze einfach
ab. Ah, exellent. Wir gucken uns das einfach ab. So. Ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok. Wir kopieren das jetzt einfach blind aus dem anderen und gut ist. So. Ah, so ist
das fein. So mag ich das. So ist das schön. So ist das schön, das gefällt mir. Gut,
dann machen wir mal die Workspaces. Kriegen wir auch ein paar gescheite Icons. Verschieben
wir das mal auf Workspace 2, machen dann Firefox aus und überlegen uns mal, was für Emotes
gut passen könnten für Workspace Icons oben. Ich glaube, ich hab bei dem anderen das hier
für Terminal. Gucken wir mal. Vielleicht weil er noch auf ist. Ah, yes, exellent.
So, was passt noch für ein schönes Emoji? Also, ich hab normalerweise meine Workspaces
so, dass ich, ähm, übrigens ist es falsch rum, wie ich das hier gemacht hab. Auf dem
ersten, auf dem ersten hab ich immer mein Browser auf, auf dem zweiten hab ich immer
mein Terminal auf und auf dem dritten hab ich normalerweise immer einen Editor oder
eine IDE auf. Das heißt, die Dinger kriegen auch dementsprechende Icons. Was ist ein schönes
Icon für Browser? So was hier, hä? So ein Kompass oder... Also, es gibt natürlich auch
die Variante anstatt Emojis. Ähm, da Image-Fonts. Äh, Image-Fonts. Naja, es gibt keinen Fuchs.
Das sind halt die stahlen Emojis, da gibt's keinen Fuchs. Ach so, du meinst so nen Fuchs.
Ich hab schon wieder zu Big Brain gedacht und dachte, es gibt nen Firefox, aber nen Fuchs,
nen Fuchs gibt's bestimmt. Das Globus-Icon hab ich aktuell, aber irgendwie mag ich das
nicht für. Guck, das Globus-Icon hab ich aktuell. Aktuell hab ich hier Globus-Icon,
äh, Terminal und, ähm, so nen Editor für links. Aber, das ist nicht so meins. Fuchs
finde ich, ist ne gute Idee. Das da. Das ist ne richtig gute Idee, auf die ich gerade
gekommen bin. Big Brain, wer hat's geschrieben hier? Fuchs. Äh, der NN-Drops, der ist, der
kennt, der ist hier. Massive. Six-Hand. Da isser. Das finde ich ne richtig gute Idee.
Das gefällt mir, das gefällt mir. Mit dem Fuchs, das ist nice. Das ist sehr, sehr nice.
Mit dem Fuchs. Oh, ich hab keine, ich hab noch gar keine History für die Shell. Das
ist natürlich, das ist natürlich an Noob-Style kaum zu überpieten. Also ne Shell ohne History
kannst du ja nicht verwenden. Wie soll das funktionieren? Shell ohne History. Oh. Und
dass wir ne ordentliche Shell-History, History in der Shell kriegen, brauchen wir das hier
für. Weil jetzt speichert er nämlich auch die Kommandos, die drin sind und shared die
Sicht zwischen Sessions. Das brauchen wir. Wichtig. Ohne History geht nix. Gut, sehr
fein. So, was, was passt denn für nen Editor noch gut? Aktuell hab ich ja, wie gesagt,
das hier als Icon. Aktuell hab ich das hier als Icon für mein IDE-Editor-Feld. Das passt
auch, man muss ja auch mal editieren, das passt ja auch ganz gut. Das passt ja auch
ganz gut. Taschenrechner. Ich glaub ich lass das mit dem Memo. Das gefällt mir, das gefällt
mir, das gefällt mir recht gut. So, den Rest lass ich ohne Icons, weil ab vier wird's
schon schwierig mit dem Finger hinzukommen. Also ich switche eigentlich nur viel zwischen
eins, zwei, drei. Ab und zu vier. Aber eins, zwei, drei sind meine Hauptdesktops. Und die
andere verwende ich beim Bedarf. Auf der Arbeit hab ich zum Beispiel auf sieben, auf sieben
hab ich auf der Arbeit nen Browser auf, wo ich immer, wo ich im Discord bei uns drin
bin. Top Secret. Wo ich ab und zu mal guck was im Discord so passiert. Da ist hier, da
ist ganz hinten. Der Wine Works Best. Das hat jeder so, das hat jeder so seins. So,
das ist doch jetzt schon echt gut benutzbar. Was, was brauchen wir als nächstes noch?
Leute, was, was brauchen wir noch? Also, wir haben unser Visual Studio Code, wir haben
unsere.NET IDE, die wir aus irgendwelchen nicht erfindlichen Gründen nicht installieren
können und nicht starten können. Warum können wir das nicht starten? Ich will garantiert
das nicht immer über, über JetBrains starten müssen. Welche Status? Das ist i3-Status-Rust-RS-Downsend-Cowsay-Lolcat.
Ah, die Roffi brauchen wir ja noch, dass wir einen ordentlichen Launcher haben. Ja, das
ist wichtig. Und vorher natürlich, wir müssen noch eine.NET installieren. Und sonst können
wir vergessen mit.NET Zeugentwicklung. 3, 2, 1. Brauchen wir und dann brauchen wir noch
ASP.NET. Das D-Menü kommt jetzt eh weg. Das D-Menü kommt eh weg jetzt. Das D-Menü wird
jetzt replaced. Einen Clipboard-Manager brauchen wir noch. Das D-Menü wird jetzt replaced
hierdurch. Ja. 30. Hierdurch wird das D-Menü jetzt ersetzt. Zack. Oh je. Show. Ach du,
meine Güte. Run. Ah, yes. Warum findet er dann meine IDEs nicht, WTF? Kann es sein,
dass es beim installieren abgeschissen ist irgendwie? Not installed, not installed. Yes.
Kann es sein, dass es beim installieren, dass ich jetzt irgendwie abgebrochen hab oder so?
Normalerweise sollte ein Desktop Link hinzufügen. Ah. Das kann sein, dass ich den Installationspfad
für die Toolbox nicht im Pass drin hab. Das kann natürlich sein. Wahrscheinlich sogar.
Ja. Ja und die run. Gucken wir gleich mal, wenn er den Kram wieder installiert hat, ob
das daran lag. So, was wir in der Zwischenzeit machen können ist, wir können mal uns ein
aktuelles ordentliches Rofi-Theme aussuchen. Das da, ich weiß nicht. Ich nehm meistens,
also aktuell sieht mein Rofi-Theme so aus. So. In der eigentlichen VM, wo ich es verwende.
Ich hab bei mir auf der Arbeit, hab ich jetzt folgendes. Das da. Allerdings mit angepasster
Farbe, weil die Standardfarbe eklig ist. Was du fire slates. Gibt's gar nicht. Ist
es was, was extra ist zum runterladen? Achso. Können wir mal ausprobieren. Slates. Ja,
das zeigt warum. Ich find das, ich hab's jetzt bei mir auf dem Notebook mittlerweile so auf
die Padding. Hat irgendjemand? Wie installiert man den Kram? Klonen und installersh ausführen
oder wie? Installersh, das sieht so nach Windows aus. Na, readme ist overrated. Richtige Hacker
brauchen keine readme. Guter Code dokumentiert sich selbst, weißt du noch. Ich vermute mal
Klonen und ich vermute mal Klonen und installersh. Ich hab in installersh reingeguckt, da sieht
nicht böse aus, was er da macht. All, bam. Who cares. Seamselector. Ja, ich hab's, ich
hab's. Seamselector. Slate, da ist es. Das gibt's zweimal. Slate 1 und Slate 2. Wow,
wie viele Sidebars haben wir denn hier? Aha. Okay, da kommen wir uns die Seams mal an,
was wir hier zur Auswahl haben. Das gefällt mir nicht, das gefällt mir auch nicht. Wobei
das geht, das geht noch. Aber das sieht mir zu Material-Android-Design-styleig aus. Gefällt
mir nicht, gefällt mir nicht, gefällt mir nicht. Ne. Oje. Ojejoje. Oh. Grip. Das mag
ich nicht. Das ist sehr fancy. Ui. Flamingo. Ab bei 90% frage ich mich, wer überhaupt
auf die Idee kam. Elm oder Game Steal Rechner. Das geht noch. Das ist, das ist, das, das
geht noch. Warum ist der Kram kaputt? Gruffbox. Gruffbox Dark ist kaputt. Ja. Ganz Gruffbox.
Grip, Grip, Gruffbox. Indigo. LB. Material. Supply, Supply. One Dark. Monk. Das ist gar
nicht schlecht. Man muss sich erst ein bisschen dran gewöhnen. Man muss sich erst ein bisschen
dran gewöhnen, aber eigentlich ist das ganz cool. Das ist sehr ähnlich zu dem, was ich
gerade hab. Das ist ziemlich ähnlich zu dem, was ich gerade habe. Aber das finde ich eigentlich
ganz hübsch. Jetzt noch mit Icons und so. Paper Float. Paper. Pop. Purple. Wer kann das
lesen? Wow. Sidebar. Sidebar. Side Tab. Slate. Slate finde ich auch ganz nett. Solarize
ist überhaupt nicht meins. Okay. Wir gehen mal, wir nehmen mal Dings hier. Wir probieren
mal One Dark aus. Mal gucken, wie das mit Icons aussieht. Nur mal gucken, wie das mit
Icons aussieht. Select A. Ach nee, Icons muss man ja selbst angeben, ne? Show, Show, Icons.
Ich kann ja tippen. Icons. Ist doch eigentlich ganz nett. Oh, der ist gut. Der gefällt mir
der Dark Trooper. Der gefällt mir. Aber der sieht mit dem Emoji-Font mit Joypixels nicht
so gut aus. Hier erkennt man, was es ist. Hier, hier nicht so wirklich, ne? Ja. Gucken
wir mal. Joypixels. Was haben wir da? Joypixels ist halt der einzig ordentliche Emoji-Font
für Linux. Es gibt noch den Google-Font, aber der gefällt mir nicht. Ich kann das nicht
hochskalieren. Ich kann nur eine globale, nur globale Font-Size machen. Wurde bei euren
Azubis die Abschlussprüfung schon verlegt? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich hab glaub ich die
letzten zwei Monate mit keinem Azubi mehr geredet. Der letzte, der bei mir war, der
war ja erst, war ja hatte jetzt erst angefangen. Letztes Jahr. So ein Zauberer für eine IDE
wäre auch nicht schlecht. So für Magic. Ich könnte mir aber da auch irgendwie einen
Döner oder so einen Taco hinmachen, weil dann hab ich vielleicht mehr Bock Sachen fertig
zu programmieren, wenn da ein Essen-Emoji drauf ist. So eine Nudelsuppe ist auch nicht
verkehrt. So eine Nudelsuppe vielleicht, oder? Ich lass es erstmal so. Weinglas Pfeifert.
Exzellent. Das ist ja schon für Wein besetzt. Gut, also dann machen wir unser Rufi-Launcher
mal hin. Also hundertprozentig gefällts mir noch nicht. Aber ich lass es erstmal. Jetzt
müssen wir noch sagen, dass wir Show D-Run. Nee, oh Gott. Die ganzen 30-Milliarden-Optionen.
Wie konnte man das jetzt ändern, dass das Zeichen, was der oben anzeigt. Also was ich
ändern will, ist das hier. Dass hier nicht D-Run Doppelpunkt steht, sondern dass da einfach
nur das da größer als steht. War das nicht Show D-Run Show? Oder war es Minus P für
Prompt? Das kann es doch kein Mensch merken. Display war es, genau nicht Show, es war Display.
Display Run, genau. Display D-Run. Ah, yes, exzellent. Wobei das mit dem Doppelpunkt
natürlich ziemlich mies aussieht. Dann lassen wir das. Dann machen wir einfach nur, einfach
nur so. Auch gut. Kann ich mitleben. Big Brain Chat, ja. Warum kein Font mit Clicker? Meinst
du damit die neuen Programming Fonts, die quasi kein größer Gleich machen, sondern
dann so einen größer Gleich in einem haben? Meinst du so einen Font? Das gefällt mir
nicht. Da erkenne ich die Zeichen nicht. Ne, ich mag das nicht. Ne, ne, ne. Ich hab
das mal ausprobiert. Ich komm damit überhaupt nicht klar. Es ist Gewöhnungssache. Also
sprich, dass man anstatt so was hier, anstatt hier ungleich zu schreiben, hat man halt so
ein Zeichen. Das ist bestimmt cool und schön, wenn man sich dran gewöhnt hat, aber ich
kann kein Code mehr lesen, sobald ich diesen Font aktiviert hab. Zu Small Brain dafür.
So, jetzt haben wir unser Rohfee drin. Das ist doch schon mal schön. So. Und da brauchen
wir jetzt nur noch eine wichtige Sache, und zwar einen Clipboard-Manager. Und da hab ich
letztens was richtig Cooles gefunden auf GitHub. Green Clip. Das ist ein Clipboard-Manager,
der hat... GitHub hat's geschafft. Die Sterne sind wieder da. Die Sterne sind wieder da.
Die Sterne waren die ganze Zeit verbackt, solange man nicht eingeloggt war. Na, Gott sei
Dank, das ging mir nämlich auf den Kegel. Ich will mich auf dem Handy gar nicht einloggen,
aber ich will die Sterne von den Repos sehen. Das war jetzt eine Woche lang verbackt, dass
du, wenn du nicht eingeloggt warst, die Sterne nicht gesehen hast. Green Clip. Verbackt. Ja
was, wie soll man es dann sonst nennen? Oder die Leute haben genug geheult, dass sie es
wieder eingeführt haben. Moment, wie startet man den Kram jetzt hier? So. Guckt, und das
Coole ist, wir haben jetzt hier einen Clipboard-Manager. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hier Sachen kopiere,
oder sonst was, und führ den Clipboard-Manager aus, dann hab ich hier eine History, was ich
im Clipboard hatte, und wenn ich es anklick, hab ich es wieder im Clipboard. Ich könnte
ohne Clipboard-Manager gar nichts mehr machen, ehrlich gesagt. So viele Sachen von mir leben
nur in meinem Clipboard-Manager und sind sonst unwiederbringlich weg. Also ich könnte gar
nicht mehr existieren ohne Clipboard-Manager. Ach ja, und das Coole ist, dass man es durchsuchen
kann. Packages. Das braucht man. Das ist, das ist wirklich richtig. Ich will mich aber
gar nicht, ich will die Github App nicht auf dem Handy. Ich will mich gar nicht einloggen
auf meinem Handy. Irgendwo. So, machen wir die E3-Config auf und sagen, Start Clipboard-Manager.
So, guck, und das Coole ist jetzt, also ich hab jetzt das hier in meinem Clipboard. Das
da ist in meinem Clipboard. Wenn ich sag, ach Mist, ich hab doch, ich will jetzt eigentlich
was anderes einfügen, dann, ach Quatsch, ich kanns euch ja noch gar nicht zeigen, weil
ich hab hier den Clipboard-Manager noch gar nicht gekeybindet. Und zwar geht der auf P,
der geht bei mir immer auf P für Paste. So, da ham man. So, also ich hab hier gerade das
hier im Clipboard, ne. So, wenn ich sag, ach Mist, ich wollte eigentlich was anderes
einfügen, dann geh ich in meinen Clipboard-Manager und sag, ach Moment, ich wollte doch hier
irgendwas mit, mit irgendwie Green Clip einfügen. Das da, wähl ichs aus und dann hab ich wieder
Green Clip im Clipboard. Essenzielles Feature braucht man. V, ne, nicht V. P, Paste. Ach
ja, und ein Feature brauch ich auch noch, das find ich auch äußerst praktisch. Das
muss ich mir aber auch aus der anderen V-M kopieren, nämlich das hier. Hat irgendjemand
eine Ahnung, was das hier macht? Ich mein, ich zeig's euch, aber vielleicht haben wir,
der Chat ist ja heute so wahnsinnig big brain, vielleicht weiß es der Chat auch. Und zwar,
ich zeig's euch, was das macht. Gehen wir hier mal raus. Start noch mal neu. Und ihr
werdet sehen, ich habe jetzt, wir starten Firefox, wir starten ein Terminal, wir starten
meine IDE. Ja, Hippo das, ja genau, das kommt, das geht in die richtige Richtung. So, Evaluation
for free, jawoll. Continue. What? Ich hab doch Darkseam ausgewählt, nämlich das Rollen
das Programm, oder? Das ist da immer wieder gelöscht. So, noch mal Setup Wizard. Nein,
das ist doch ein Core. Next, die Fault Plugins, wir brauchen alles weg, alles weg. Next, start.
Evaluate. Continue. Hab noch paar Emojis für Tab 3. Oh, der Muffin gefällt mir. Ich weiß
zwar nicht so genau, was der Muffin mit einer IDE zu tun hat, aber der Muffin gefällt mir
für Tab 3. So, also was das ganze macht ist, wenn ich jetzt Windows nach Secu drücke, hab
ich ein Scratchpad Terminal. Da kann ich einfach ein Terminal einblenden. Und das ist sehr
praktisch, da kann man nämlich seine Hintergrundsachen drin laufen lassen und kann sich das Terminal
quasi als Overlay machen. Das heißt, ich brauch kein Terminal mehr in der IDE oder sowas.
Das ist wirklich praktisch. Das ist so ähnlich wie Quake Terminal und Ja, Quake und sonst
was. Das ist quasi so eine Art Dropdown Terminal. Das einzige, was ein bisschen doof ist, ich
guck mir gleich an, wie es in JoyPixels aussieht, die zwei Sachen, die du hier gepostet hast.
In JoyPixels sieht das ganze, wow, wow, fuck, fast. Ich hab ein bisschen viel copy pasted.
Also so sieht das Zeug in JoyPixels aus. Ein Regenburgeneis. Ich weiß zwar nicht genau,
was es mit der IDE zu tun hat, aber ich muss sagen, irgendwie gefällt mir das Regenburgeneis.
Das ist so schön Copper Pride, das Regenburgeneis. Das machen wir jetzt. Zack, Regenburgeneis,
so muss das sein. Hat zwar überhaupt nichts mit der IDE oder einem Editor zu tun, aber
gefällt mir das Regenburgeneis. Das hat was. So, fuck, jetzt hab ich vergessen. Was wollte
ich jetzt gerade machen? Wo war ich gerade dabei? Leute, wo war ich gerade dabei? Big
Brain beschwören aus dem Chat. Also wir haben den Clipboard-Management-Hammer. Terminal
Transparency, nee, da war ich nicht dabei. Overlay, Terminal Overlay, genau. Eine Sache
ist ein bisschen verbackt. Das hab ich hier in meiner VM noch nicht ange- Also erstens
fällt mir mal auf, dass der Rand weg ist. Das ist schonmal fail. Der Rand sollte eigentlich
nicht weg sein. Das sollte eigentlich den Rand haben, das Terminal. Und was auch ein
bisschen verbackt ist, ich hab's jetzt geschlossen, das Terminal. Jetzt geht's nicht mehr auf.
Das war mal Trick 17. Und zwar, ähm, hier unten, wo wir das Terminal starten, da starten
wir nämlich, ähm, da starten wir nämlich nicht einfach ein Terminal, sondern wir starten
eine ZSH. Und da drin starten wir TMAX. Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert. Mal gucken,
ob das jetzt funktioniert. Und da zeige ich euch gleich, was ich- Oh Gott, ich muss die
Tasten richtig mappen. Irgendwann der Anfälle bei. Dann zeige ich euch, was ich vor hab.
Das funktioniert, okay. So, und jetzt, und jetzt, und jetzt mal mal Trick 17. Pass mal
auf, jetzt haben wir nämlich hier, while true, do TMAX, end. Und was jetzt passiert
ist, wenn ich das jetzt schließe, macht das einfach wieder auf. Dass die Lösung, finde
ich, ziemlich, ziemlich, Fiveheader, muss ich sagen. Guckt ihr, oh, oh fuck, ich hab,
es geht nicht, es ist kaputt. Es ist kaputt. Ich hab's, was hab- Jetzt hab ich den verkehrt
gemacht. Warum geht denn das nicht? Also, also von der Idee her sollte das doch funktionieren.
Guckt mal, von der Idee her sollte das klappen. So. Boah. Ich bin verwirrt, warum klappt das
nicht? Moment. Moment. Ha.
Bin ich jetzt, bin ich jetzt komplett hängen geblieben? Warum geht das nicht? Hab ich,
hab ich irgendwie einen Sündagsfehler in meiner Schleife brotten? Ach, oh man, Leute.
Es ist done. Es ist done und nicht end. Bash Script, Kacknoob. Guckt euch das mal an. Es
ist done. So. Jetzt funktioniert das nämlich auch. Oh, Scratchpad. So, wenn ich mein Scratchpad
jetzt schließe, ja, zack, schließe, geht's nämlich direkt wieder auf. Jetzt kann ich
gar nicht mehr schließen aus Versehen. Das ist das, was ich machen wollte eigentlich.
Jetzt hab ich mein Scratchpad immer am Start. Egal, wo ich bin. Das ist äußerst praktisch,
so ein Terminal am Start zu haben. Auch als Overlay, wo immer man es gerade braucht.
Huge. Was machst du gerade? Ich konfigure Manjaro, sodass man schön verwenden kann.
So. Das lässt sich doch jetzt schon wirklich ganz gut verwenden. Was braucht man als nächstes
noch? Ich brauch mein Notizprogramm noch. Da verwende ich immer das Ding hier. Das da.
Das ist leider auch drin. Da verwende ich immer das hier als Notizprogramm. Äh, das
ist die neue Form, die wir im Stream benutzen in Zukunft. Und warum schreibt hier keiner
was? Weil du wahrscheinlich gerade zu einem sehr ungünstigen Zeitpunkt gekommen bist.
Normalerweise ist immer recht viel los. Äh, als Notizprogramm verwende ich immer das Ding
hier. Und was mir daran gefällt ist, dass es das einzige Notizprogramm ist. Was ich kenne,
also als erstes müssen wir natürlich dieses Mal auf Dark 7 stellen, weil sonst geht ja
gar nichts. Das einzige Notizprogramm, was ich kenne, das einen Windows-Client hat, Mac-Client,
Linux-Client, ähm, Android-Client, iOS-Client, gleichzeitig neben Notizen auch To Do's kann,
inklusive Plattform unabhängigen Notifications. Für mich ist das das beste Notiz-Todo-Programm,
das es gibt. Nur mal so angemerkt. Also wenn einer ein gutes To Do-Programm sucht, dann
ist das auf jeden Fall das Richtige. Starten wir jetzt auch standardmäßig. Und machen
wir einen Shortcut dafür. Und zwar Windows-Taste N für Nodes. Bäm. Ich tue jetzt Windows-Taste
M und dann hat man ein Notizprogramm am Start. Und dann mache ich es wieder zu. Und am besten
machen wir das auf Floating, dass es quasi oben drüber kommt. Aber damit kann ich erst
mal leben. Ja gut, also ich würde sagen, so insgesamt sieht das doch jetzt schon mal
wirklich ganz brauchbar aus. Gibt's jetzt noch was, was wir unbedingt machen müssen?
Fällt euch noch irgendwas ein? Weil mir gehen jetzt gerade die Ideen aus, was wir noch machen
müssen. Hm. Oh, beste, beste Sound. Leute, was haltet ihr davon, wenn wir mit, ähm,
Depot für Dot-Files erstellen? Hehehe. Einen Kernel kompilieren, oh ne, heute nicht. Kernel
kompilieren ist gar nicht so spektakulär, wenn man die passende Konfig für hat. Alle
User mit, ähm, ich hab ja fast alles drinne jetzt. Also fehlt ja nix. Achja, eine Sache,
weil wir ja in neustart das Memboard pushen, ja. Weil wir in letzter Zeit relativ viel
Frontend-Gedöns machen. Äh, installieren wir uns noch nen, noch Node und nen, nen Javascript
Package Manager. Den brauchen wir. ASCII-Iquarium, oh ja. Das ASCII-Iquarium brauchen wir natürlich
unbedingt. Ohne das ASCII-Iquarium geht gar nix. Aber ich glaub, wir haben das ASCII-Iquarium
schon installiert. Hallo Max, wie gehts dir? Mir gehts gut. Und wie gehts dir? Kirsche
B. Ich mein, hier kanns einem ja gar nicht schlecht gehen, weil wir sind ja hier im Chrome
Compile Stream. Da werdet ihr nicht viel sehen. Außer, dass ich auf den Terminal gucke. Und
nicht passiert. Chrome Compile Stream. Pass. Okay, funktioniert. Ähm, das hatten wir eben
hier noch. Es gibt auch Leute, die sleep streamen. Was? Es gibt Leute, die schlafen im Stream,
wenns wirklich. Aber, aber warum? Ich mein, ich mach sonntags immer einen Aufwachen-Stream.
Aber ein Aufwachen-Stream ist ja das komplette Gegenteil von sleep streamen. Oh Leute, ich
weiß, was wir noch mal probieren können. Ich hab nämlich letztens was gefunden. Eine
Sache, eine Idee hätt ich da noch. Weil aktuell haben wir ja hier, ähm, das ist aber, das
ist aber ein bisschen monka-tos, kann ich euch gleich sagen. Das ist ein bisschen monka-tos,
was wir jetzt machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es funktioniert. Go ist installiert. Ich glaube
nicht, dass Go installiert ist. Ähm, aber wir müssen Go auch nicht installieren. Und
zwar, was ich gefunden habe, ist, es hat jemand, es hat jemand die Apple Emojis extrahiert
aus IOS und hat ne Schriftart gebastelt, was die Unterlinux funktioniert. Und wir können
mal probieren, ob wir was hinkriegen, Apple Emojis, ähm, Unterlinux zu verwenden. Da
hab ich nämlich auf GitHub, hab ich auf GitHub letztens was gefunden. Äh, Apple Emojis,
ähm, das hier, genau. Das hier. Das da. Von der Idee her sollte es so einfach sein, wie,
ich mach erstmal den Downloads. Wo downloadet der hier eigentlich aktuell hin? Wo ist denn
so das Standard Download Ordner von Firefox? Downloads. Ja, aber den Ordner gibt's nicht.
Ach doch, gibt's doch. Ich hab nix gesagt. Ähm, so, und was sagt der jetzt? Einfach,
einfach ersetzen, ne? Oh, was geht mit dem hier ab? So, und jetzt einfach Replace User
Share Fonts Emoji 1. Okay, wir haben kein Emoji 1 Font, wir haben, oh, ich muss meine
Keymappings mal richtig machen. Äh, wir haben kein Emoji 1 Font, aber wir haben ein Joy
Pixels Font. So, und was sagt der jetzt? Man soll den hier, ich backupe mir den mal kurz.
Ich backupe mir den Font mal, weißte nie. So, und er sagt, wir sollen den Font ersetzen
mit dem hier. Oder? Also unseren aktuellen Font mit dem hier. Da bin ich mal gespannt,
ob das funktioniert, ob wir jetzt gleich Apple Emojis haben. Wenn ja, wäre das ein wenig
Monka Toss. What the fuck? Wow. Was ist das? Das hat schon mal nicht gut funktioniert.
Okay, das sind auch keine Apple Emojis. Wow. What the fuck? Monka. Okay, Leute, exit.
Okay, das sind definitiv keine Apple Emojis. Das sind definitiv keine, okay, das hat nicht
funktioniert. Das hat nicht funktioniert. Na gut. Nee, ich muss es nicht neu aufsetzen,
ich habe doch den Font gebackupt. Ja, haben wir doch gemacht.
Was? Aber wir sind schon in Downloads. Moment, habe ich das vielleicht verkehrt gemacht?
Habe ich das verkehrt gemacht? Moment. Hä? Moment, was habe ich denn eben gemacht?
Benutzte P-Haul nicht mehr. Nicht mehr, weil es für Twitch und YouTube aber richtig funktioniert.
Hä? Was habe ich denn gerade gemacht? Den habe ich ersetzt, oder? Den habe ich gerade
ersetzt. Ach, ich habe den dahin kopiert, kann das sein? Was eigentlich total bescheuert
ist? Okay, ich glaube, das mit Apple Emojis funktioniert nicht. Ach nee, das war ja von
hier. Ah, ich glaube, das mit Apple Emojis funktioniert nicht. Oh, schade, dass das nicht
funktioniert. Drop der Stream Frames, das kann sein. Das kann sein, dass Unity Media wieder
rumspackt. Ja, Unity Media ist gerade wieder am abscheißen. Unity Media, please. Kommt
noch ein Update zum Software um, da hat sich noch nicht viel getan. Der neue Software steht
hier neben mir, halb unter der Heizung. Okay Leute, ich glaube, Unity Media möchte, bzw.
Vodafone möchte, dass wir aufhören mit sinnvollen Sachen im Stream. Okay, das funktioniert
jetzt. War das zu viel Bandbreite gerade für? Okay, bis zu wie viel Bandbreite schaffen
wir das? Vier hatten wir eben, das ging nicht. Ha, das ist zu viel. Okay, drei. Drei scheint
zu sein. Zwei? Auch nicht. Ja. RIP. Da müssen wir kurz warten, bis Unity Media in Shit wieder
zusammen hat. So Leute, diesmal versprochen, richten wir das noch fertig ein. Wir haben
es ja im Großen und Ganzen schon. Ich mache mal kurz die Emojis wieder heile. Ich mache
mal kurz die Emojis wieder heile. So, ich habe mal kurz, ich habe mal die Emojis wieder
heile gemacht, ja. Hat es sich jetzt ausgewodafoned oder leckt es immer noch? Boah, das ist ein
richtig nicer Effekt. So, mal gucken, ob ich jetzt wieder ein bisschen mehr Bandbreite
kriege. Vier? Vodafone, please. Bless RNG, Vodafone. Nein. So ein scheiß Anbieter.
Ja Leute, es gibt wohl nur bis maximal zwei Ambit ohne Fehler durch gerade. Das liegt
an meinen WLAN SSIDs, ja ich weiß. Wenn das da Vodafone Supportmann sagt, dann muss das
so stimmen. Der Vodafone Support Typ ist wahrscheinlich der richtige Oberhexer-Man. So Leute, also
ich würde vorschlagen, wir machen so genug Linux Einrichtungen für heute, aber wir haben
jetzt zwei Varianten, was wir machen können, weil ich muss ja noch was essen. Ich muss
ja noch was essen. Ich habe das Essen hier seit ein paar Stunden neben mir stehen. Poggers
ist busy. Wodafuck. Was ist das für ein Fehler? Was ist das für ein Fehler? Wodaf- das hatte
ich ja noch nie. Ach, ich weiß, woran das liegt. Das war, weil wir zum ersten Mal Suspended
haben und ich habe halt 16G RAM. Da musste er erstmal 16G RAM in eine Datei schreiben.
So, also wir haben jetzt folgende Variante. Wie gesagt, ich muss ja noch was essen und
wir haben ja eh nicht so viel Bandbreite zur Verfügung. Das heißt, wir können jetzt
entweder noch eins, zwei Essen-Videos gucken und danach mal schauen oder wir gucken uns
mal die neuesten Stellenanzeigen auf StepStone und Golem an. Dafür brauchen wir nicht so
viel Bandbreite und ich kann ein bisschen ablästern, während ich futter. Wann gibt's
auch wieder ein Video vom Haus? Das nächste Video vom Haus, was es gibt, ist über meine
Heimautomatisierung, aber da muss ich mir Gedanken machen, wie ich das am besten zeige.
Okay, was soll ich euch lieber stellen anzeigen oder Essen-Videos? Holgemerkt, Essen-Videos
sehen wahrscheinlich scheiße aus mit 2 MBit. DB Stellenanzeigen, oh Gott, das halte ich
nicht mehr aus. Was hat denn die Telekom eigentlich für neue Jobs in Frankfurt? Jaja, der Frontend
Architekt, den kennen wir ja schon. Ja, Frankfurt. Nee, Kratsch. Frankfurt. 60329, 60329. Stellen suchen,
gibt's nicht. Das Ding ist nicht in der Lage anscheinend ein bisschen Umfeld zu suchen.
Okay, wir haben da was. Da gibt's ein Technical Sales. Feels pain, man. Vodafone-Jobs. Keckwee,
das müssen wir mal gucken. Die Sucker. Okay, was haben die hier? Diversity, oh yes, excellent.
Da darf ich jetzt nichts Falsches sagen, sonst kriege ich hier gleich wieder geflamed. Passt
zu, zu Woder. Oh ja. Was? Moment, warum soll ich mich mit Name registrieren? Okay, Bruder
muss los. Bester Vorname. Bruder muss los. Nee, Vorname Bruder, Nachname muss los. E-Mail-Adresse.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man da nicht, da kann man bestimmt Fake eingeben, ha? Passwort,
okay. Weiter. Okay, auf geht's. Bruder muss los. Scheint ja gut zu funktionieren,
sofort alles. Okay, also, am liebsten gehe ich so mit meinen Kollegen um. Ergebnis orientiert,
formell, freundlich, informell. Schließt das eine das andere aus. Ich find, Ergebnis orientiert,
freundlich und informell, beides gut. Hä? Informell ist auch nicht verkehrt. Was ist
das für ne Usability? Man kann, wenn man sich verklickt hat, kann man nur alles löschen.
Man kann nicht toggeln oder so. Na gut, was erwarte ich bei Vodafone auch? Kann nicht
sein, dass ein Internet Provider Webseiten machen kann. Das müssen die ja auch gar nicht.
Okay, also ich muss sortieren, was mir am wichtigsten ist. Am wichtigsten ist, am wichtigsten
ist, dass ich gut mit den Leuten klarkomme. Ich will mit denen nicht dicke, dicke, dicke
Kumpel sein oder so, aber ich will mit den Leuten klarkommen. Ich hab keinen Bock mit
totalen Spasten zu arbeiten. Ergebnis orientiert, informell, formell. Okay, weiter. Next. Das
ist huge UI Design, das geht auch so schnell. Sieht man nach einem Third-Party-Service aus?
Naja, das ist immerhin ein Third-Party-Service. Hallo. Ah, das geht schon weiter. Das ist
immerhin ein Third-Party-Service, den Vodafone sich ausgedacht hat. Okay, im Team, ich vermute
mal, das sind so 15 Fragen oder sowas. Im Team ist meine Stärke Verantwortungsbewusstsein,
Eigeninitiative, Commitment. Ist Commitment und Eigeninitiative nicht... Ist Commitment
und... Na nee, nee, gut, Commitment ist eher so nach dem Motto, wie bin ich hinterher,
dass was, dass was passiert. Okay, am wichtigsten ist für mich, im Team ist meine Stärke.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich mach, ich mach öfters mal Dinger, wo ich weiß nicht so genau, ob
ich die machen sollte, aber ich mach so. Was weiß ich? Keine Ahnung, ich leg jetzt einfach
irgendwas an. Meine beste Fähigkeit ist Teamfähigkeit, Rationalität, Kreativität, Genauigkeit. Ja,
geht so. Ja auch, auch. Also wenn ich was mach, ich mach die Sachen, wenn ich Sachen
machen, mach ich die meistens relativ genau, weil ich will ja nicht den gleichen Kram
noch mal machen müssen. Und ich sag's immer wieder, programmiert ist was Kreatives. Also.
Okay, Kreativität, Genauigkeit, Rationalität, Teamfähigkeit. Meine ideale Führungskraft
führt schwerpunktmäßig durch... Ja, Rest mir egal. Hallo. Der Rest ist mir wurscht. Also,
wo ich echt keinen Bock drauf hab, ist übermäßiges Coaching. Also technisch gesehen weiß ich,
was ich mache, besser als meine Führungskraft. Dafür kann der andere Sachen deutlich besser.
Und ich sag, der kann eigentlich sagen, die krieg ich überhaupt nicht gebacken. Aber
übertriebenes Coaching ist nervig. Vergabe von Zielen ist auch wichtig. Man muss ja wissen,
was die von einem wollen. Vergabe von Verantwortung, ja Coaching ist das letzte für mich. Im besten
Fall sollen meine Leistungen gemessen werden an. Ja, wenn ich was ordentliches mach, soll
sich das auch auszahlen. Wenn der Chef jetzt zuguckt, wieso, war doch nichts Schlimmes
dran. Mein Chef macht es ja auch so. Der weiß genau, dass jeder sehr unterschiedliche
Stärken hat. Ich mein, mein Chef ist nicht so, dass der von der Technik überhaupt keine
Ahnung hat. Das stimmt ja auch nicht. Der hat ja lange Zeit genug in der Technik gearbeitet.
Aber so rein im Linux-Bereich und sonst was, ist dem glaube ich auch klar, dass wir besser
Bescheid wissen als er. Dafür kann der organisatorische Sachen um Längen besser als ich. Um nicht
zu sagen, da kann das halt was, was ich teilweise überhaupt nicht auf die Reihe krieg. Ist
ja nicht schlimm, ist bei. Dafür gibt es ja unterschiedliche Stellen. So, individuelle
Leistung finde ich gut. Wenn man was Gescheites macht, sollte das auch belohnt werden. Gute
Initiativen, kommt drauf an. Teamleistung, je nachdem um was es geht, das ist jetzt sehr
schwer zu sagen. Das ist wirklich sehr schwierig zu sagen. Keine Ahnung, ich klicke jetzt einfach
mal irgendwas. Boah, wie viele Fragen kommen denn da noch? Das ist, ehrlich gesagt, ist
mir die Umfrage zu Resident Sleeper. Ich will mal gucken, was rauskommt. Ich klicke jetzt
einfach mal schnell durch. Ich will mal gucken, was rauskommt. Komm her, das hört gar nicht
auf. Das sind 15 Fragen, aber das sind sonst wie viele Fragen. Das sind 30 Fragen oder
so. Einfach nur wissen, was sie uns am Ende anzeigen. Ah, yes. Okay, jetzt können wir
auch zu Vodafone passen. Playlist, das ist ein Top 100 Nintendo Songs. Branche wählen.
IT. Internet und IT. Geschlecht. Oh. Anzeige ist raus. Anzeige ist raus. Vodafone. Vodafone,
die. Die muss ich flamen auf Twitter jetzt. Äh. Moment Leute, das geht so nicht. Das
geht so nicht. Da muss ich einen Screenshot von machen. Da muss ich einen Screenshot von
machen und die auf Twitter ein bisschen trollen. So, weil hier steht Diversity. Guck das,
ihr habt das gesehen. Da steht Diversity. Und da kann ich nur Mann und Frau auswählen.
Bam, Vodafone. In your face. Save Screenshot. Zack. So. So geht's ja nicht. Kein Wunder,
warum das Internet so schlecht ist. Die mussten mehr divers sein. Ja, ich will. Zum Glück
verstehen die meisten Leute ja noch. So viel Spaß. Wer sagt, dass das nicht böse gemeint
ist. Aber Vodafone kann man damit schon ein bisschen flamen. Hier schreiben sie Diversity
und hier kannst du nur. Ich mein, it's, it's ernsthaft. Das ist wirklich 2020 nicht mehr
zeitgemäß. Gerade im Technikbereich und gerade dort, wo alle auf, auf divers und auf weltoffen
und, und jeder kann, wo, wo, wo man nach außen hin quasi so, so rüberkommen will und sich
das Image geben will. Und dann hat man das da nicht drin. Das ist schon fail. Angemeldet
als Bruder. Aufgaben im Gebiet wählen. Ähm. Was hat so eine Sachbearbeitung? Gibt's auch
so was wie Programmieren? IT und Softwareentwicklung. Wohnort. Äh, Frankfurt. Ausbildungsgrad.
Was soll denn Ausbildungsgrad sein? Hoch. Oh, keine Resultate. Ah, hier. Ihr Kriegssamen.
Ah, yes. Exzellent. Gibt's da auch so was wie Ausbildung oder so? Gibt, gibt's da auch
was für uns Relevantes? Exzellent, ja. Der mittlere Schule. Ich mein, was man, wen juckt
dann, was man in der Schule mal gemacht hat. Äh, äh, Berufserfahren. Okay, weiter. Was?
Ich will Vodafone matchen und nicht irgendwie sonst wen. Oh, 79% matchen wir mit Vodafone.
Äh, von, von, von 2016. Oh, gibt's das, gibt's das auch in, gibt's das auch in 2019?
Ach, tatsächlich. Gibt's das 2019. Das ist cool. Das hören wir uns das nächste Mal an.
Äh, so, also wir sind, wir matchen, wir matchen zu 79% mit Vodafone, nachdem wir random, random
alles angeklickt haben. Sehr schön. Okay, was hat denn Vodafone jetzt wirklich für
Jobs? Äh, Berufseinsteiger und erfahrener. Mission, Mission Rat. Ah, also was, Leute,
was meint ihr ist besser? Mission Rat oder die Magenta-DNA? Ich kann mich nicht richtig
entscheiden. Mission Rat oder Magenta-DNA? Kundenservice-Custom Relationship. Nein, IT-Technik
zeigt's mir. Personalgedöns, Marketing, bla, Finance, Digi... Was ist digital? Also, das,
was wir in Deutschland nicht sind, aber was ist digital überhaupt? Oh, Marketing. Oh,
ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Ist ja mal gut jetzt. Ähm, Continuous Delivery Administrator ist
nicht IT und Entwicklung, sondern, sondern, sondern digital. Okay. Bist du auf Jobs? Oh,
ne, bin ich nicht. Haben wir was in Frankfurt? Ne, die sind alle Düsseldorf. Äh, so, das
sind jetzt IT-Jobs. Was haben die da zu bieten? Leiterarchitektur, ja, natürlich. Ähm, Software-Engineer,
Informatiker, Werkstudent, Professional Supplier-Manager, Expert Planning und Roll-Out-Mobile-Network.
Agile, Agile-Tools an diesen Werkstudenten. Ein Pflichtpraktikant. Was ist denn der Unterschied
zwischen einem Praktikant und einem Pflichtpraktikant? Habt ihr neben euren Azubis auch Werkstudenten?
Ja, haben wir. Radio Guidelines, Team Leader. Da hatte digital aber mehr mit, mit, mit Technik
und IT zu tun, als Technik und IT mit Technik und IT zu tun hat. Innovation Garage mit Schwerpunkt
Business Model Innovation. Meine Fresse. Pflichtpraktikanten wollen eigentlich nicht da sein. Ach, deswegen
ist es Pflicht. System-Expert-Operation. IT-Software-Engineer. Big Data Real-Time Analytics.
Oh, das war's für mich. Oh, Leute. Geht los. Der Rest ist langweilig. Was haben wir denn
zu bieten? Leiter-Architektur ist Schwachsinn. Ähm, Software-Engineer. Blablabla. Blablabla.
Es ist ziemlich blöd, dass man von dem eigentlichen Browser-Fenster, wo man so viel Platz hat,
nur so wenig sieht. Bist du bereit für eine Zukunft, die so aufregend sein wird wie nie?
Jetzt mal rein mein subjektiver Eindruck. Die meisten Leute, die Entwickler sind und
was mit Technik machen, die haben gar keinen Bock drauf, dass es jeden Tag anders ist.
Bist du bereit für eine Welt voller neuer digitaler Möglichkeiten? Oh, das ist Huge-Marketing-Text.
Bereit für Vodafone. Bereit für Vodafone, ja. Oh je. Framedrops, Leute. Framedrops.
Ich bin sowas von bereit für Framedrops. Warum ist eigentlich du entwickelst Software
kleingeschrieben und der Rest groß? Software entwickeln ist nicht wichtig als Entwickler,
glaube ich. Das ist auch ein geiler Satz. Du entwickelst
Python-Libraries und effiziente Algorithmen. Das würde schon komplett reichen. Das würde
schon komplett reichen. Aber da hat irgendein Marketing-Mensch oder irgendein Personal-Mensch
gesagt, den Satz können wir so nicht stehen lassen und deswegen hat man hinten dran gehängt
als generische Building-Blocks für unsere Teamarbeit. Das hier wäre doch vollkommen
ausreichend gewesen, oder? Du entwickelst Python-Libraries und effiziente Algorithmen.
Ja, gut, schön. Als generische Building-Blocks für unsere Teamarbeit. Hier, alles klar,
ich weiß, was ihr von mir wollt, was ihr meint. Hier, ich hab keine Ahnung, was ihr mir sagen
wollt. Habt ihr eine Ahnung, was mit generischen Building-Blocks für unsere Teamarbeit gemeint
ist? Legit nicht, ich hab keine Ahnung. Man entwickelt interne Tools wahrscheinlich, vermute
ich jetzt mal. Die haben bestimmt ein eigenes Jira nachgebaut. Ein Mining-Truck. Also sogar
nur Google hat 65.000 Begriffe. Da ist ja unten drin, ist alles in Ordnung. Okay, das
ist glaube ich absichtlich, dass die erste Zeile kleingeschrieben ist. Das haben wahrscheinlich
die User-Interface-Experten von der anderen Stelle gemacht. Ein abgeschlossenes Studium
in Vorwartung, vergleichbar in Qualifikation. Sehr gute Programmier-Kenntnis. Ja, das
ist wenigstens mal eine Aussage. Würde man als Programmierer erwarten, aber man weiß
nie so genau. Frontiertes Know-How im Bereich Systemarchie und Datenbank. Erfahrende Umgang
mit Software-Entwicklungs- und Support-Tools, Git, Jenkins, Linux-Kenntnisse. Ja, alles
in Ordnung. Neugier nach neuen Techniken und Interesse an Cutting-Edge-Methoden. Sowie
ausgeprägte analytische Fähigkeiten. Alles okay. Vollzeitnahe Teilzeit. Oh, das ist was
für mich. Aber es ist ja nicht in Frankfurt. Natürlich verraten sie mal wieder nicht,
was sie bezahlen. Verraten sie ja alle nicht. Attraktive Vergütung. Betriebliche Altersvorsorge,
das ist schon mal ganz gut. Umfassende Weiterbildung, je nachdem, wie es umgesetzt ist. Individuelle
Förderung deiner Talente. Das kann komplett für den Arsch sein, je nachdem, was sie damit
meinen. Es gibt nämlich auch Läden, die sind der Meinung, sie müssen mich alle 5 Minuten
für irgendwas coachen oder so. Das wird mir dann auf den Keks gehen. Flexible Arbeitszeitmodelle
mit Teilzeit und Homeoffice. Klingt gut. Ist wahrscheinlich auch gut. Manche verstecken
sich hinter dem Begriff flexible Arbeitszeitmodellen so nach dem Motto, wie du willst Samstags
23 Uhr keinen Netzwerk-Switch tauschen. Das ist aber nicht so agile. Aktive Unterstützung
bei der Kinderwahl. Das ist gut. Das ist wirklich gut. Unterpflegefonds. Das ist gut. Je nachdem,
was sie damit meinen, aber das überzeugt viele. Gibt es echt noch Firmen, die Stellenanzeigen
gehalten haben? Nee, die meisten nicht. Wobei ich gar nicht verstehe, warum man nicht mal
ungefähr eine Hausnummer sagt. Oder, ja doch, ich verstehe, warum man nicht eine Hausnummer
sagt. Man will sich nicht die Karten gucken lassen. Natürlich ist mir auch klar. Aber
ich find's doof. Weil attraktive Vergütung schreiben alle. System Expert. Okay, das ist
immer das gleiche hier. Du hast IT im Blut. Jetzt geht's ab. Das ist, wenn man die Cutting-Edge-Methoden
einsetzt von Vodafone, dann hat man IT im Blut. Du kennst dich in der Online-Welt aus und möchtest
mit deinem Wissen den Betrieb unserer Online-Umgebung unterstützen und permanent verbessern. Das
ist auch bitter notwendig, dass der Betrieb eurer Online-Umgebung verbessert wird. Blablabla.
Ah, nee. Second Level. Okay. Java. Meine Güte. Ich bin raus. Ach, das ist langweilig
bei Vodafone. Da war die Telekom besser. Die Telekom hat nämlich noch mehr übertrieben
mit geilen Buzzwords. Sowas gibt's noch. Gibt noch IT-System-Elektroniker. IT-Hunter.
Was macht man als IT-Hunter? Was kann man sich darunter vorstellen? IT-Hunter. Head-Hunter.
Vielleicht. Spalank. Hab ich noch nie was mitgemacht. Ich weiß nur, dass es teuer ist.
Scheint aber recht verbreitet zu sein. Langweilig. Sales. Was haben die so viel mit Pharma-Branche
zu tun? IT-Forensik? Sollten die sich nicht um unser Internet kümmern? Gut, die Telekom
hat überall ihre Finger mit im Spiel. Ein DevOps-Engineer. Den hatten wir schon mal.
Äh, IGIT-SAP. Den hatten wir schon mal, den DevOps-Engineer. Aufgabe. Ah, yes. Excellent.
Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom
hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine
sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute
Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die
Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat
eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr
gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige.
Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat
eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr
gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige.
Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die
Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat
eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr
gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige.
Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die
Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat
eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr
gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige.
Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine
sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige.
Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige. Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige.
Die Telekom hat eine sehr gute Anzeige.